two
hello hello welcome everybody to the h3
podcast
youtube is number one
and we have empirical evidence to back
that up now thank you guys today is uh
august 24th a beautiful summer wednesday
joined today by the very funny tim
dillon thank you for having me i
appreciate it thank you very funny man
thank you you know you're one of the
sweet of you
a lot of comedians like
you know they don't i feel i don't know
what it is but it's hard to make people
laugh in a special format like that yeah
well not easy yeah
well
i'm glad that you enjoyed it yeah yeah i
mean it's uh it's always better live
right stand-up's always better live it's
always more fun
live it's hard to translate now yeah
when he captures like i look at it and i
go yeah it's good but live is just buy
the tickets live did you not like it i
feel like i liked it you know i i yeah
again
i have done i did 51 cities
we did 51 cities
and it was uh it was an amazing tour
and i i thought the special was was
really good it was a good representation
of it but compared to doing it live and
the feel of it live
it's just to me comedy is such a live
sport i see by the way it's a real hero
which was on netflix yeah and i was
sweating and i looked horrible you know
it's all that so then all that is part
of it you look you go uh but then it's
like people go you're not selling what
are you talking about who cares but you
know it's that you're in i'm in an
ill-fitting shirt yeah you know the
first show we did the fire alarm went
off really and like the denver fire
department had to come and
he connected that great
it's a great you got heckled by the uh
fire department yeah there was they had
to remove so many drunk people from the
audience you know in the second show
there was a guy just screaming i'm from
long island is that right yeah just
still the psychopath going i'm from long
island
i'm from long island before he even got
to his scene ben and other people had to
go get out like get him out of here he's
going to be a problem
so you know i mean but all said and done
i'm glad that it it it went off you know
without a hitch well i enjoyed it
thank you
netflix paid me i think thirty dollars
okay so it's pretty
pretty good and i want to thank them and
i appreciate them and
yeah did we say sponsored by hellofresh
important we
this episode is sponsored by hellofresh
oh well i just kind of did okay thank
you dan
um yeah
how was working for netflix is that your
first special you sold them i did a
15-minute special with them a few years
ago and um
and then this is the one that they
didn't want this one i think and they
were just like if you know we shot it
and then sold it to them um and and uh
you know they they have been what was
what i'll say about them is they didn't
give me any notes which was really cool
because they're kind of well they lost
80 of their stock price
so i think they basically would just
like if you want to just heil hitler
just we need someone
to watch this they don't care what's
going on so yeah i mean and you did a
few times that was my favorite yeah in a
joke
uh
in a satirical way oh yeah but yeah i
think they what was cool about them was
they were literally like hey
we're just putting it on so that was as
a comic that's all you can ask for
you know
you know how was the walk
there was the guacamole oh the money no
i mean you're not you know
20 million they lost no no they well
they spent all the money on the legends
yeah they spent all the money on all of
the legends and that's great
and uh and so the younger guys got you
know we all got kind of the same deal
which was just kind of like hey
you shot it we'll cover that and then
here's a few dollars oh yeah do they do
the exposure play it's exposure it's a
global platform although it's not on in
like the netherlands people are
screaming at me going it's not on in
finland
uh i don't know but it's on in the u.s
and the uk i think australia okay um so
it's you know it's a two-year licensing
deal so after two years i can get it
back and then
you know i don't know do what i don't
know what i'll do with it yeah you can
put it on a zip yeah it's also a lot of
topical stuff yeah so it has no value
two years from now right right it
questionably has value now two years
from now it will have less than no value
yeah yeah well maybe you could sell it
like uh the wu-tang album yes
yeah
just one person own it yeah that's a
good idea you know
i'll get i'll give you i'll start the
bidding yeah sorry i appreciate it
yeah so um
i wanted to show you something we took a
photo together yes
and uh you're very tall i didn't know
that you're six you're not sick i think
it's six one one and a half i believe
yeah i don't think it's enough to
measure get the measure i don't think
it's that you've got to be six too
because you saying you're six one may it
yeah causing a problem for me
right well i think but i think if you
measured me i think um
i don't think i'm that much can we get
the measurement out yeah we can i'll do
it okay
yeah i'll do it i think i'm six one and
i'm not wearing like i'm wearing new
balances well you're gonna have to check
those off that's fine but i'm not
i'm not in a platform shoe yeah yeah you
know
um
but yeah i think 6-1 okay well let's
find out but anyway i was uh doing i was
doing the pork noy which is when you
stand on the tippy toes photos right i
didn't even know that was a thing until
i saw portnoy doing it but people like
to be taller
yeah well it's humiliating to take a
photo next to one who's like hulking
over you right right right
even the perspective is right
humiliating right yeah for sure
yeah but you got to own it right you got
to own it and just
i thought okay listen that is what it is
so anyway i learned this trick from
portnoy let's do it so i i
should i stand up yeah stand up go ahead
yeah we're so we're going to see how
tall tim dillon is here
i'm going to say six one and a half i
think you're six thank you more yeah i
think you're six too
yeah
six one and a half oh wow you're so
exact that's that's not good for me yeah
no i i believe it would be a weird thing
to lie about if i came in here and i was
just completely
misrepresented a beef measured me and i
was six foot but you made me feel like
tiny but i have flat shoes maybe it's
flat shoes it could be that
i don't know but anyway here's portnoy
so he does this tippy toe thing which
he's a short guy i get but what a what a
[ __ ] animal to tippy toe this man
these this this i have a problem with
you
maybe they're both not choosing to do it
is it a reflex oh like me and you have
the tourette's like i have mts motor
ticks oh yeah right yeah motor tick
syndrome absolutely
and uh i'm wondering if it's a tick
now it may not be because he doesn't do
it all the time he he may only do it
when he's standing next to someone
but this is a
i just realized that maybe they're both
doing it they both might be doing it oh
yeah it's interesting maybe let me check
his feet
yeah yeah he is see that ruins mine oh
so that's a bit it's a joke yeah
yeah it's a bit yeah you really
shouldn't have pointed that out
damn you and you're facts
oh i was like dude he's flexing on this
yeah first look it's like what's wrong
with this guy yeah it's a fun it's a fun
bit they're having fun with
all right all right all right it's not
good no not that good then
yeah so um
how you been good you know things are
good yeah you know i mean we're just
yeah i talk [ __ ] for a living you can't
really complain right
i mean you know i mean that's kind of
a dream job per se yeah we're familiar
with you
get it
uh you know and i mean things could
always be better
like what you know well like everything
right personal can we improve personally
well i could be healthier i could have
more
self-respect i could be in love i could
have meaningful relationships outside of
work i could connect with my family i
could connect with friends i could
establish a social network i felt was
fulfilling right all of those things
might improve that sounds like it sounds
miserable your life sounds horrible no
not i wouldn't say it's horrible a
horrible you know horrible is like you
know disease and right despair
you know but
i i think i'm i'm coming along i'm
getting by yeah i always feel bad for
anybody that has to tour because i feel
like that has to make your life so
different it's harder it's hard it's
harder to have
you know i exaggerate obviously there's
people in my life i love but
it's harder when you're all over the
place although and i i've gotten
addicted to moving around so much and
the chaos of it all
that i you know i think i just
need to detox from that yeah you were in
texas yeah for a minute it was a brief
stay you well your intention was to move
there right yeah the intention was to
move there i'd never lived anywhere
except new york or los angeles and i
moved to austin texas
um and i liked other parts of texas you
know i've fans in texas there's other
parts of texas that were you know but i
moved to austin
um a friend of mine moved there joe
rogan i don't know if you know him and
he
does a podcast he does a podcast and uh
i don't think so i don't think you could
find that
i've never seen a picture of i don't
think so all right
and he moved there and he loved it and
he does love it you know he really
enjoys it by the way do you i have yeah
i drink out of um
are drinking out of straws lately yeah
on a straw
oh my god
this is
this is tremendous
this is
[Music]
this is like a scene from a movie called
nothing but trouble which was a classic
movie with like the inaccurate and chevy
chase and to me more where they're all
eating these disgusting
oh my oh my god
what's that movie about ah are we
actually using it i mean how is it how
is it
there's a lot of hot dog flavor to it
more than i expected
you know what i gotta be honest it's a
it's a fun summer treat
that's rough it's a dirty water dog yeah
you have done half of your water which
is amazing now it has a youtube has a
seal so now
that was good no no no no no
anyway you were saying i i i didn't vibe
with it i didn't like it it's you know
yeah it's rough that's rough ethan it's
going to be
i mean that is a that is a heinous
that is a heinous activity
it's heinous
it's really rough
oh god is he vomiting
am i oh okay yeah
well
man
what the [ __ ] hot dog did you buy sam
that's just the phallus should i ever
veggie it was a veggie one
oh no how would you do that how dare you
i can't believe you've done that get
abroad why do you need a real one for a
gag
well i i just
i could have eat i could have swallowed
it
anyway go on well it was it wasn't for
me you know it was uh i hated it and i
was vocal about it i feel like
i told everyone i hated it and
you know i i hated everyone i met and
all of the things that
people were doing i hated and
i didn't understand what was going you
know everyone there was like this is the
next city right and i didn't get it
i didn't understand it the lake is the
color of sewage okay it's a deep green
sewage lake uh there are homeless people
this idea that there's no homeless
people there they're there is a lie
they're homeless people there and by the
way
it's like you know it's every you know
so it's like this idea that listen la
has problems we all know that it has
problems but you know there's shootings
there there's lots of shootings so it's
not like it's armed right yeah but it's
also like people get drunk
they shoot each other it's part of the
culture it's fun right it's not
something it's a it's a fat bachelorette
party goes down there a bunch of women
get off a trolley and they just start
going you know
and it's not my business to tell them to
stop right
there's one sushi restaurant in all of
austin
you can't eat fish there are there is no
produce
you know there is like i get it it's
like
they put brisket in the water this in
boston is not a bed this is not a bed in
austin this is something you know so to
me it just wasn't
and then the other side of it is like
these tech guys
who are you know inviting you to their
houses and you go to these like massive
estates you're talking about elon right
not elon elon i went to one thing with
him
uh that was just seven people and it was
new year's eve and it was somewhat
boring it was fine he's clearly a very
brilliant guy and but it wasn't like it
wasn't like a a hoot okay it was like
fine but there's other guys down there
that will invite you over and like they
don't eat
uh
they don't
do any like they we played pickleball
with one guy they want to live forever
these guys yeah it's kind of a ex
machina thing and it's just not like
inviting they don't eat they don't eat
pizza no they don't eat anything they
have like nuts they have like packets of
things that satiate them i mean look at
jeff bezos look at his body
human things bother them
human things but and one of the guys was
telling me like when you walk in you're
like hello and he's like and because
they're not socially
you know with it there's other words for
it but let's just say they're not like
fun socially like there's many yeah
things and uh they'll just you'll be
like hey how are you and then they'll
just start right in there like you know
there needs to be another city built
that competes with austin you know we
need to build another city that competes
with austin i'm going to build a
university and i'm going to have
different you know different parkways
and that way we can reduce the pressure
on the traffic and you go all right this
is i can't it's intense you know it's
intense that's the word for it yeah you
want a new water is that okay uh i would
love one thank you very much i
appreciate it
yeah you can leave mine my hot dog water
here
it's a town of breakfast tacos college
kids
uh tech sociopaths
um you know and and god bless everyone
that enjoys it yeah and and and when you
move somewhere and you don't like it
you're the [ __ ] if you stay right you
have to then leave and go everybody it's
a city for people that didn't want to
eat they want to eat tacos outside
that's all they want to do really it's
people that come under that well it's a
lot of it really does though it really
actually does it's people that are like
it's people that are like i just wanted
to like move here
and like be myself and like austin lets
me be myself and what that translates to
is i wanted to make horrible decisions
right and have them work out here
because it didn't work out in any of the
three other cities where i was a lazy
drug addict right well so more
affordable or at least it was it was not
anymore yeah the market's been [ __ ]
insane yeah the texans they i mean they
hate californians right like it's a war
if you go there with a california
license plate i hear that it's like on
site it's on site yeah and it's in my
special yeah it's time i mean
many like there was a woman who was
cutting my hair and she's like honey
here's what y'all you need to come to my
church oh god and you need to meet my
daughter cause she's funny too and then
i'm like okay at least
show me cause i'm gay so i don't i don't
really have anything to do with women
you're gonna do it not
sexually
but i said maybe if she showed me like a
gorgeous
texas bombshell i'd go you know what
maybe i do want to give it a shot right
i'll give it a shot yeah but her
daughter has blue hair
is like you know what i mean like the
absolute opposite of not necessarily
your type not my type so it's like these
are the worst people austin is like if
the proud boys in antifa got married and
had a city where you just like so
everyone's kind of the worst version of
that's a lot you know
it's interesting because there's so many
people
i guess i don't know if joe rogan was he
moved there and started like a whole
movement and he loved he's always loved
it he always loved it when he lived here
he liked it and i guess i get it if you
you know he hunts and he like yeah
there's more natural stuff right you
know which is great i don't you know
yeah yeah okay but yeah i don't know i
just don't buy that people are moving
there and being happy i don't believe it
but the thing is certainly
there's one thing they go there's no
sales tax okay that's cool right
houses are cheaper debatable now yeah
other than that it's like man
if i'm making
let's say if i'm making a million
dollars right it's not worth it for me
to save a hundred thousand dollars and
live in [ __ ] texas i understand miami
you know i've always understood miami i
understand the beach in the ocean i
understand like hey i want to save money
and then here
uh but texas i went there and i thought
like you know listen austin is a
specific version of texas too
um that is
kind of weird like it's like not
like if you go to texas you almost want
texas give me dallas give me like women
with big hair
like yeah give me that yeah but austin's
like this weird
thing where it's just like these strange
nerds i've heard that yeah it's odd the
whole thing's odd nothing is
nothing works and the food is atrocious
it's some of the worst food in america
okay that's interesting because
texas touts that they have this great
cuisine well well here's the problem
um is is that you have to be like a
drunk college pig
to enjoy it like you have to be like
someone without any distinction who's
never been anywhere talking directly to
the people of texas right now well
austin okay because dallas has great
food and houston has really good food
and austin has some good barbecue right
right you can't eat barbecue all the
time because you'll die yeah
you know what i mean you just don't feel
good with it sure um but the food there
is just now it's very underwhelming to
be honest and you're a food guy right
i'm a bit of a food guy here's the thing
i've should talk to austin for three
years two years yeah you left and here's
the garage
everyone that comes to me that lives
there not one person is defense not one
human being i said hey [ __ ] you man that
one person has said that everyone kind
of goes yeah i get it you know what to
be honest though the people that get
defensive yeah are people that live in
places they know or are yeah like these
two like i like this one barbecue spot
run by two lesbians they just got
indicted for tax fraud
so that's awesome you know they just got
excited
united like fraudulently doing workman's
comp it's in the paper
that's awesome good barbecue though it
was really good the ribs but it's fallen
off and now i know why because they're
committing crimes instead of cooking
right right so you know that's a problem
that's you guys got to be careful with
that you know it's not worth it the
financial crimes but i am i think i
might be doing a live podcast there and
it's a good city and i'd love all of you
to come out uh for that thank you yeah
after i destroy it i always have to say
but hey you know
people all come together yeah well he's
got his price [ __ ] on la too i i like la
but it is a true thing like people all
outside of la [ __ ] on la yeah i moved to
new york for a year yeah and i didn't
even realize this is a thing i mean i've
lived in socal my whole life right and i
moved to new york and everyone's like
ellie [ __ ] sucks everybody welcome to
new york the real world and yeah there's
like this culture of hating l.a yeah
part of part of what i didn't like about
austin was there was this idea that
everyone had to be relentlessly positive
like in new york i was around people
that always hated new york and now i'm
around people here that hate l.a i've
never not hated where i've lived and i
think it's a very
rational thing to do is to look around
you and go look
but this idea that this inevitability to
austin and it's like we all have to wake
up and not notice anything that's wrong
and say and then you're on a team and
it's gross to be on a team
denial denial you mean there's like the
old folks who are red yeah and the new
folks they just transformed the city to
a more liberal sebastian it's not even
political as much as it is just you have
you have people that are
truly true believers which is the worst
thing ever i mean like christians well
sort of but it's they believe in a city
so that to me i i go
that's weird to me i i would rather you
believe in
a god or
your life or your talent or your family
or like there's something weird to me
about having to constantly sell a city
every day be like aren't you glad you're
here that's interesting because i always
hear people talking about austin like
that yes i've never heard a bad thing
about it no you're spreading the gospel
i i
i have taken it upon myself yeah like
like john the baptist to go around
and tell people that yeah it's i mean
it's like 103 degrees right now i have a
house i still own a house there we go
back the grass is yellow
because it just you know i mean there's
nothing you can do yeah the water heater
exploded the well is too hot the well
the wells [ __ ] that guy you drink out of
wells well i have well water but that's
scrooge why do you want to drink out of
a well well because i have our own water
for the race war
right right right well that well you
should have opened with that yeah
don't you get it
yeah so um
by the way just so you don't think i'm
totally insane
this was something that we saw in real
life oh yeah
this was this viral video of this
legendary man
at a ball game
who
invented this move
he uh
despines a hot dog
and i could see those flavors maybe
working harmoniously more than water
yeah you got a respect with a beer it's
beer
yeah you gotta respect that
but i had never seen anything like it so
i wanted to try it
so shout out to this man yeah you tried
it it was me and austin you gave it a
shot not good now
that wasn't good
yeah so um
well you know i like the idea though
that like everyone's just running away
from homeless people
they're like yeah yeah they're all in
l.a let's go to [ __ ] well there's
texas there's no homeless people yeah
it's kind of a nationwide does it bother
you that it is nationwide it's
nationwide la's got a lot of there's a
lot of problems so when you when you
drive in in la you go
it is very difficult because you have
these how you know every show in l.a is
about real estate
every single year like all the reality
shows yeah
and there is an irony that when you
drive through the streets you just see
tents and then every pop culture
representation of l.a it's like well you
know what i like closer you know what
would be a really good reality show is
like you know homeless uh realty yeah
where like because i know they fight
over nice tents nice spots there are
tents that are better than other tanks
that's a fact yeah yeah yeah i'm not
even trying to be insensitive there are
things you look at and you go ah there's
there's class issues going on there's
mice all over the place yeah
you know and uh but no la has that
unique issue because of the because the
policies are not great but it's the
weather too if you wanna if you're gonna
be homeless somewhere
you know this is a good weather place to
be homeless my take on the homeless
problem in l.a yeah all over california
is that people travel from all over the
country yeah specifically to la so you
have other states that's right they have
their people
for what who are homeless for whatever
reason coming here because the the
policies are good for home for homeless
people
out of it yeah let's go the other way
but it's like let's just go we're we are
the top homeless destination in the
world right i take friends now that come
when they visit i take them to skid row
and i'm proud of it i go there's ten
thousand people right here it is and
many people like disturbed and i go what
the hell is wrong with you they go this
is horrible i go why because you have a
house i go this is great like i say
let's be proud of it let's let's just
listen ella's a great place you got to
be a little bit of a sociopath to enjoy
it
and that's okay you have to you have to
be a little bit you can't focus on every
image
and then focus on every person you see
giving birth on the street you have to
just go to the meeting you do
yeah but so my thing is like the whole
country is sending their homeless people
and you know i feel like we need some
federal funding to deal with this
massive problem it can't be the state's
responsibility to take like a whole
country yeah part of it is the high
rises too like la hate's high rises so
new york
is is better suited to deal with this
because they have high rises right so
when when people talk about building 30
000 units of affordable housing the idea
that if if if many of them are in a few
buildings it's much easier to do than
building 30 000 single family you know
one of the big crisises of l.a is the
zoning is right right they don't let you
build up there's only a few streets
there's a few because a lot of people
just don't want the views ruined or they
don't like they don't like vertical
living
or they don't want yeah
they probably just don't want riff raff
or whatever coming to their whatever it
is yeah but i mean so there's definitely
issues here but there's issues
everywhere
everywhere you went to texas yeah and
there was homeless people there not as
many but there were there were a few
okay and um
they're there
it's there's there's there's everything
there's problems everywhere i don't
think you can move away from homeless
like you know if you
a lot of people who move to texas i hear
them going like amongst all the other
reasons they go i'm getting away from
all the homelessness i just love the
idea of running like rich ass people
yeah running away from home it's also
it's weird because rich people weren't
that affected by homelessness at all
exactly they're in the united states
exactly yeah you're not living in skid
row
um but no there's fi there's violence
everywhere there's problems everywhere
you have they were shoot there was a
mass shooting in austin when i was there
you know like on
6th street where everybody gets drunk
and you know brandishes weapons and you
know so it's there's going to be
problems everywhere you just have to
come to grips with the fact that you'll
probably die and it will probably be
violently
i mean wherever you know what i mean is
where i do not want to come to the group
well no sure i would like to avoid that
yeah
yeah um what do we do about it you know
what's what's your solution oh i mean
it's it's it's i think it's it's a
problem that
it's very tough what you would need to
do i think
is
number one get on board that it's a
problem because la is so big that like
manhattan beach has nothing to do with
beverly hills that has nothing to do
with pasadena that's nothing to do with
downtown is that sure so you really got
to get on board that is a problem and
then you gotta you gotta really i think
you gotta have that conversation about
vertical living to be quite honest right
i really do think because everyone who
goes i'm gonna build 30 and i'm not i
haven't studied the issue but like it
does seem i go to new york i go well
what's different here and they go
we have
massive buildings where we can give
people
space that's units yeah that i think
that might be part of the thing that's
actually a really good point i think
that's oh that's been a huge problem in
la that's why the housing market here is
so [ __ ] up there's literally not
enough houses for people here there's
and and people get pushed out and it's
so so and then you know so i think that
like that seems to be just from a
standpoint of looking at the actual
setup of the city that seems to be one
of the controversies you know what
actors
i think you're right on the nose there i
wasn't expect i wasn't expecting like a
yeah like a pretty good answer to that
yeah i don't know i mean or we could
build them a mall
oh because
we built them a mall rick rousseau built
the uh grove yeah and i think if we
built them all just for homeless people
what kind of stores would they have in
there the things they need right and let
them play in the fountain and let them
go on the trolley you know if the grove
has a little let them go on the train
this could energize them i don't know
this is a guess
this is an idea yeah i want to show you
something and get a read on this um
so howie mandel i'm sure you're aware of
yes so howie mandel very popular on tech
talk okay yeah
and um he's very pc he has a very clean
image the guy he's a family friendly man
that's his whole stick right right
that's the bread and butter well he
posted
a tick tock it's too vulgar to show so
i'm just gonna show it to you
and and i haven't stopped talking about
this is my favorite thing that's
happened not just of this year but
possibly the decade uh dan how can we
show this to tim so that the audience
can't see it uh well i i can put it on
the screen right now and yeah don't
switch to it don't switch to it yeah
yeah
so how we just unannounced put this up
uh
and it shook the world the tiktok world
when my friend neil bent over this
happened does somebody know is this
covid related and if it is what do we do
about it
oh yeah
wow now that's a prolapsed that's a
massively prolonged dana anus
and he put that on his tic-tock yeah
publicly it was up like for a full day
it had like three million views this is
the guy who hosts deal or no deal yeah
right okay i just want to review yeah
yeah i just want to review that um
yeah that's what they call a
it's what they call a brand
identification issue
he's uh unsure of you know
yeah that's interesting i mean his
agents
were probably crawling on the floor to
grab it it was up for like 17 hours that
was so powerful about it and then if you
go to any of his comments now on any of
his videos it says we will never forget
right yeah and that's part of what you
know children saw that probably a lot of
let's go over to
howie mendel's page they said let's see
what he's doing if you could pull it up
uh if you don't mind dylan i mean
there's just
just put a pro so i can show just to
analyze the prolapse i mean that is a
special special prolapse there's nothing
better than a guy who goes i'm a little
sick of this clean image
let's try because this is what he's
doing here he's going let's try
something
and he's thinking maybe that'll work i'm
the edgy guy you know but you can even
see the [ __ ] hairs that kind of it's
spread out this is
crazy
i'm not looking so crazy
that he put this on his tick-tock
he's the host of a family game show yeah
i mean
america's got talent shane yeah
yeah so talk of the town i'm homies with
howie i keep trying to get him to call
in and talk about dude yeah he's a good
dude
he won't he says i'm laying low on the
prolapse
i get it this is by the way he's asked
me to do his podcast several times and
now probably he not overseen that
if i go on i gotta talk about this yeah
bring it up yeah bring it up it's
important
we keep the dream well that's what
happened ethan did go on his podcast and
then i think this happened right after
this is what you do to people yeah oh my
gosh
no i'm not i'm not even kidding i went
on a podcast and i tore i just it was
just so much drama yeah afterwards yeah
i mean this is
this is amazing i wonder like what the
call was to him like somebody going hey
um
that tick-tock
that you just posted and he's like the
one with the anus they go yeah that one
uh we're finding that that's not doing
great
we yanked it it was going and it
actually was doing work so great yeah it
had like three and a half million views
oh it was crushing people were loving it
i was sharing it with everyone i knew
it's amazing
yeah but so can i ask you a question
we've debated this in here is this an
act a sexual act or an act of
unintentional prolapse or intentional
prolapse i believe it's an unintentional
prologue really but i don't know i
thought it was an
intentional prolapse here's what i'm
basically why'd they cut around it like
that well that's interesting i thought
maybe it just broke in that form like
just busted through bust it through like
that
that's crazy but i don't know it's
possible it busted through but that's
interesting the idea of that that it was
a premeditated prolapse
yeah i think i think there's there's
group there's groups of people that are
like this there are people that do that
yeah yeah and i mean i've heard i don't
know if you know about fist fest
fist fast yeah no i'm aware of this
thing i don't know what fist well it's
there it's they take it yeah they take
it all the way right and so they do
stuff like this with each other so
they call it like a red rose and they
love the prolapse anus it's interesting
how you get that yeah it's interesting
what what lines cross that lead you
there
you know but
everyone's got to make the living
um but yeah
this is an interesting uh choice for him
yeah so we're actually commissioning a
carpet it's like if pat sajak from wheel
of fortune put up like cannibalism
like a video of people just eating
people
with like no ex and then tried to make a
little joke about it you know
it was like hey i'm hungry but not this
hungry you're like what are you doing
you psychopath oh
i love howard for this yeah we're
commissioning uh a carpet there's this
guy that makes these really incredible
carpets yeah life
yeah perfect detail yeah so we're how's
that going are we getting this made in
the carpet sam or who's talking to him
uh sam is uh she stepped away for a
moment but yes it's it's proceeding yeah
it's going to be a huge one like 12 by
12
with howie's head the prolapse oh my god
for the studio yep you love it
beautiful oh yeah fist fest by the way
so i learned about this so this is why i
think this might be intentional
wow they have a logo
yeah it's howard stern sent the guy
there to report on it and
it's actually pretty incredible to learn
about
it's wild that this is like an
organization yeah it didn't work they
had they had like you know the
conference room at a holiday inn of
course or something where they were it
was happening
oh okay monkey pox vaccine required okay
that makes sense hey
makes a lot of sense
good hey it's good to be responsible
yeah
so okay i love the idea of somebody
going hey man
i need a fake monkey pox vaccine card to
go to fist fest
because that is a sentence being said
somewhere
i'm sure it is yeah
okay here's big news let's get your take
on this wait before we uh move on
although
maybe there should be a little bit of a
buffer after that discussion but we are
at 30 minutes we should
get me in trouble with my sponsors now
you know he told me he lost a lot of
money from that
it's interesting i i was talking to him
every now and then you will see somebody
who goes way outside of what they
usually do
like every now and then i will tweet a
gofundme because someone will ask me to
and i'll be like please help this sick
child and then people be like hey [ __ ]
you [ __ ] this and i'll be like you know
guys
i know we keep it real light yeah and i
know that i'm a guy that likes it you
know but let's just donate five dollars
or not and let's move on you know yo
this is where fistfest is taking place
nice spot man
so i'm saying they don't they don't
schlub at fistfest interesting well this
isn't great this doesn't look that great
this is not the beverly hills hotel uh
it looks like an extended stay america
like
it looks like a hotel where the cops are
frequently guests yeah it does kind of
look like a fist fest
but i like that fistfest says hey no
matter what your economic strata we want
you to be able to enjoy yeah um this you
know very
violent and crazy yeah yeah sexual
experience yeah actually we still can't
do the sponsor because we now we're you
know i mean
we're gonna have to just sit silently
for 30 seconds
yeah
thanks
i'm just gonna check twitter
okay
what just happened before where
a sponsor
made us remove it because what i thought
yeah i had the same i did
what did you talk about jews that you
talked about i did i said satirically
that that
i think it was like one of the recruits
we're gonna put homeless people in a pot
put them in a big pot put them in a pod
and that was satirical right and the
sponsor was not a fan what was the
sponsor though simply safe a security
system oh you would lock them in there
you would think they would
you would think they would be on board
with that that's what i think and so
what was the one that i got in trouble
for dan
uh which time yeah could be more
specific i don't remember them maybe
there's been a few lately
there was one uh oh right you uh it was
babel the um language learning app and
you said we were talking about sex
trafficking just before that you said
make sure you you'll lower your chances
to get sex trafficked if you know the
language
a master class i said hey master class
actually this is interesting look
epstein has a class here on sex
trafficking
but i made sure i said i'm kidding right
it's a goof thanks thank you the thing
is you want to make the ad reads
interesting you want to make the money
more people buy too hard
i'm working for them
oh what was the fresh one was it about
an abortion joke about uh
we're about to do it yeah we're i'm not
doing it nope nope we're restarting the
30 seconds
okay one second
what was it dan the third one
maybe it was yeah let's talk about it
dan doesn't like a little after that
he's gonna lose a job
everyone's gonna lose their job
okay
let's just be let's just keep it going
okay
uh
ten more seconds so we're at 30. how
many how many times do you sponsor do
you get in trouble with sponsors a lot
not a lot okay
that was one of one of two maybe in the
whole time oh that's fine that's not bad
all right i think we're clear well it's
sponsored by hellofresh
we love hello fresh folks don't we yes
sir
super troopers love hellofresh
you get farm fresh pre-portioned
ingredients and seasonal recipes
delivered right to your doorstep skip
the trips to the grocery store and count
on hell fresh to make home cooking easy
fun and affordable that's why
it's america's number one meal kit abey
come on without music
uh oh he's not sitting at the station
today oh it's unmanned my magic wait
what happened you gave up on the sound
bite it was a guest episode i wasn't
going to do my shitty sound bites for
but i got no music i just just say here
an idiot selling royalty
there's usually some jovial music
royalty-free music here we go here we go
hello fresh don't get me wrong
me too
[Music]
oh yeah first result royalty-free music
oh yeah
is that a vibe is that good i like it
turn it up a little bit oh
i clicked off of it here how about this
one
okay
i love fresh
spring wiring
this feels like it starts with
hellofresh but then you have a new life
start a new life with hellofresh
you're pulling up into an unknown suburb
just
getting out of here this is every
this is every like 20 million dollar
house they say
they have this burn
oh yeah you're right the backsplash
right
beautiful white marble tile care how you
made your money it'll feel really at
home right here in beverly crest
yeah but anyway we love hello fresh um
listen you you throw up some photos dan
of the beautiful meals that are
this these are all members of our
community that have bought hellofresh
sent us pictures that's some nice
looking meals right it really does i
love hellofresh they here's what how it
works they send you a box of
pre-portioned ingredients and a little
info card exactly how to cook it you're
always going to get delicious healthy
meals and you're going to learn about
cooking too even if you're experienced
or a beginner
they basically lay it all out for you
and it's just man it's just so good
here's something that might blow your
tits off need another reason to stay in
for dinner hello fresh is 72 cheaper
than dining at a restaurant and it's
even cheaper than grocery stores because
you don't have to buy 10 pounds of
carrots that's making soup absolutely
thank you thank you back me up yes no i
the amount of times i've bought 10
pounds of a vegetable and made of soup
right you can't even count them it's
just not and then you throw them out i
throw them out because i realize i don't
have a family and no one loves me
right this whole pot of soup yeah and
then it's a it's a whole nother thing an
existential crisis yeah so go with
hellofresh so you know you can get
one for two i don't know if they have
ones i don't know if they have a single
one here's the thing here's what you do
you you just get it for two
just get it just
just in case just get it for two you
don't know what's gonna happen
or eat both or eat both
yeah which got me where i am yeah um
guys
are you uh let's see skip the grocery
store and spend more time soaking up
those summer rays it's hella fresh
market is a one-stop shop for all your
meal time needs curated a selection to
breakfast lunch snacks desserts and more
here's where it gets insane go to
hellofresh.com
[Music]
16 h3 why'd they do a bet they did they
switched they just swapped it
it used to be
h316 and then you swap it
why would they do that
no reason i have no idea my only
reasoning was maybe because it was h3
and then the number 16 so you had 316.
it was confusing what part of it was
part of our name and what part of it was
the
day go to hellofresh.com
16 h3 and use the code 16 h3 for 16 free
meals across seven boxes and three gifts
at hellofresh.com
16 h3 code 16 h3 16 for 16 free meals
free because that's hello fresh
america's number one meal kid thank you
thank you sorry to do that for you no
nature of the live you know it's the
game
we used to pre-record them because yes
we would record them separately we used
to do these epic long ones like 10 or 15
minute ads that were really funny and
some of them are on youtube and like
we'd really get into it but it would be
crazy but it would be a lot of fun
and then some of the sponsors were like
okay you gotta shorten it
that's it i don't know
i don't get it that's it they don't
understand that like yeah
if i do a big ad that's funny
people are gonna share it they're gonna
want it they're gonna watch it and they
may buy the product they should be
paying you more i agree they did not
agree and i go that extra length too
yeah
no well [ __ ] them never worthy now you
just do a quick one you know fun one hey
go and buy this
cereal that makes your dick hard or
whatever they're selling you just move
on
you know
they prefer that for some reason yeah
yeah so i wanted to ask you today it's
been announced i know you're relatively
political or aware of the happenings you
have opinions
buy-in yes 10 000
forgiveness
on student loan for anyone making less
than 125 000
it's happening he gives everyone 10 10
000 off the top if you make under 125.
interesting it's interesting because
everyone will hate it
right it doesn't work far enough it
doesn't go far enough and then the
people will go hey we don't
i think the libs will be it's better
than nothing right like i think
everybody here it seems like has student
debt it's just such an insane epidemic i
mean i had student debt that we paid off
already there's a lot of there's a lot
of student debt out there but a lot of
people say that 10 000 is like not
nearly yeah some will say it's not
enough some will argue that
it's kind of a weird wealth
redistribution from blue-collar workers
to people that went to school right yeah
you know i didn't consider that angle
yeah that's interesting it's an
interesting angle people go well there's
a lot of people that are struggling they
don't have health care they don't have
this they don't have that they didn't go
to school
and they are now subsidizing i mean
yeah what's happening in there i mean
that's what everyone should get give
them a hot dog straw
thousand dollars it's only been in here
like 30 minutes it's not aging well
scariest thing ever i don't know i mean
this is the craziest thing i've ever
seen this just eight it's already eight
why is it huge damn what is this brand
so people never buy it
come on forget but i think it was called
like lighthouse
lighthouse veggie dolls light up light
out light up white
diarrhea nothing wrong with veggie dogs
you put it in water yeah
i had one in back it was it was slamming
i had an impossible burger on the delta
flight and it was phenomenal delta every
now and then first class yeah yeah no it
was really good and i had never really
delta serving hamburgers yeah because
whenever
i find i've flown first class yeah both
times okay
every time
yeah a couple i mean who you what are
you
i just let that go
i just let that sit i'm like yeah i know
i don't want people to go people go oh
ethan's bragging about his wealth or
then sometimes people go
oh he's trying to act like he's a normal
guy right so i wouldn't be like oh so
yeah i'm just being honest right but
it's always like little finger foods and
fun i never get a [ __ ] hamburger
that's what i want that's what i want
and we don't fly that much okay well
you're you're a serial traveler yeah so
we fly a lot and then sometimes it's
good and then sometimes it's not like
the australian airline qantas is really
good in australia like from melbourne to
sydney from sydney to adelaide like
there they kill it
you're traveling on an airplane a lot
you must spend a [ __ ] fortune on
tickets fortune yeah unfortunate but i
put my producer in coach that's good
yeah is that ben i spent yeah he goes
and coach and i sit in first and as he
goes back to coach i look at him make
eye contact with him as he goes back and
say i want you to think about how hard
you work
let me tell you right now he's been in
coach a guy and ben can even back me up
here a guy vomited right right next to
you that's true yeah that's true yeah i
vomited next to him what else happened
once ben a guy
went crazy or has he started in the
bathroom so yeah
a month after the guy threw up on me
there was a guy that when you you went
to the bathroom and was smoking a
cigarette in there and like the the
flight attendants were running to the
back and
things got really crazy it's a prison
call
it's rough back back he sits there and i
know he could get hurt
and i know that he makes a good rope
yeah it's rough it is rough
and uh so that's how we save a little
bit of money
yeah yeah well it's a big but uh um
he puked on you you got vomit on you
yeah that would happen yeah he blacked
out when we took off and he came drunk
yeah no he was not drunk he just blacked
out he said he went to the doctor and
got his head scanned and he had some
weird thing and he told him not to get
on a plane that you had a brain trauma
puke on you that seems this guy had this
crazy thing
and he had the nerve he walks into first
class with the vomit oh
man have some clowns is he out of his
mind you are
telling me about this guy having a brain
aneurysm i'm like what are you talking
about i'm watching crazy rich asians and
having a torch
bend shame on you man have come on bro
you know better than yeah it's just
disgusting behavior we need a barricade
we need a wall clearly the curtain is
not enough curtain's not enough
yeah ben come on did you apologize at
least
tim was actually very upset i i did it i
was actually very upset with him
i was kind of upset with him because he
walks in the first class like covered in
vomit and starts talking to me and
everyone else at first class is like oh
thanks for bringing your drug addict
friend up no one knows he was vomited on
number one if you have vomit on you no
one knows you're not the aggressor
you're right who knows you are not the
problem right so when you come in and
you vomit all over you you look like the
problem yeah ben why wasn't your first
trip to the bathroom to clean the vomit
correct uh there was a it was uh they're
always packed at back in economy i know
you guys aren't familiar with it there's
people literally smoking cigarettes
and doing crazy things back there yeah
so i had to so how long did you have the
puke on you before you got about three
and a half more hours
and i texted him i said is this going to
bother me in the uber should we take
separate cars
in terms of the smell i literally said
will this bother me because i have a
very sensory oil factor yeah yeah but i
let him stay in the car it was fine oh
how nice it was was it a lot of puke or
a little puke it was it was a quite a
bit and it got in my backpack too oh
yeah it was about six or seven it kept
coming up and he didn't he wasn't really
aware of himself so it just kept no i
mean i think he was fine well if he he
has some brain injury and he's puking i
mean
he had a brain injury i talked to him
about it because he was very upset with
himself well he should be
and i don't think the response is for
you to be a therapist for him
he told me his doctor told him not to
get on a plane because he has some weird
nerve thing and yet he did and he did
and then he blacked out and then came
too and just started vomiting violently
well he was where was he going austin i
think we were going to austin i'm pretty
sure i know that's not right that's the
type of people yeah because he was like
hell with the doctor he probably went
straight to a barbecue place
yeah you know ribs you know
that's a that's an interesting tale
did you get uh
did you get any type of compensation
from the from the carrier for that no
and also i did not get to change seats
because it was a full flight so i said
oh my god
and they had nothing to wipe the seat
down with so it was just holy [ __ ] no he
has very bad flying luck
he'll always text me like something's
going on back maybe have him fly on a
different plane in the future yeah like
every every time's up like he texts me
goes there's a guy smoking cigarettes in
the bathroom the flight attendants are
screaming at him he's gonna have to pay
a three thousand dollar fine he he's
just now he's asleep
i'm scared ben's like i think he's gonna
get up and start trying to fight people
just mute your
phone it bothers me because i'm you know
jetblue mint now is doing really
beautiful things
pasta with italian food and i'm eating
you know uh tagliatelle or something he
doesn't even know what it is
and i'm being bothered by like tales
from the crypt of what's going on in the
back right right
yeah ben come on bro have some fun
yeah it is yeah
how are you feeling olivia she has a
vomit phobia
i'm feeling like i probably would have
killed that man
oh my god while he was puking on me i
agree with you i have not thrown up in
like literally almost a decade it's i
think that
it's like
as aware as you are or as he was you can
see that i'm here go there
over there
ben he did he didn't choose to puke on
you did he no but when he came to he was
conscious but he couldn't control
himself anymore oh he only blacked out
for the the changing out there is to the
man he was dying but that doesn't
exactly behavior it doesn't to me it
does not excuse his behavior well he
wasn't supposed to be on the plane
according to his dog that's right but
he's like the hell with him two things
can be true at once yeah right yeah yeah
i mean that's why they have the
emergency exit right for throwing people
like that out
get out that's why i thought it was
there yeah i have an emergency throw
them out
yeah okay wow um so anyway biden for
giving a lot of money huh
[Laughter]
ten grand uh to everybody here let's
watch this serious talking about it
so you haven't seen this video yet
i got no volume
hey friends for me i just wanted to hear
from you yeah two angles
oh he's got a multi-angle shout out well
you can't get through a whole video like
this without
people have shutterstock 190 000 worth
of student debt that's yes right yeah
yeah well i think that's on the high but
like 50 000 is probably medium it's good
to give him 10. it's better than nothing
he's better than you maybe
you have a student that cameron has
studied that what i mean you guys are
happy about it i mean right yeah yeah it
takes about a sixth of it away so i'll
take it i really don't get it though
because like ultimately i hope i hope
that when he gives them a 10 grand that
sally may increases the interest rate on
the rest to make up for it yeah because
that could help premium that like could
happen right i don't think so because
the interest rates are set by the
government i know but they could they
might raise they might go listen we gave
you that 10. but now we got a sticky on
the back
money on the back ass make it a watch
make some points on the back that's fine
yeah i would normally agree but uh
because i could absolutely see them
doing that but i believe i read that
actually is part of this plan is they're
locking the interest rates good okay
okay okay by the way people are saying
in chat 90 to 180 is normal i mean
that's insane yeah it's a lot there's
nothing you know oh my god look at this
comment i own i owe 190k and 90k is just
from interest that's
no matter how bad your life is right you
could be dying they will not do that for
students what but and then like students
are the people least qualified to take
on an enormous amount of debt it's like
you just finished high school don't even
have a [ __ ] credit card here's two
hundred thousand dollars crazy and by
the way yeah when i got loans they were
like insane high interest to it like
nine percent yeah i mean that's
borderline yeah that is great criminal
situation absolutely so i'm personally
in favor of getting rid of all the debt
because i do think it's absolutely
crushing a whole generation people but
the whole forgiving debt thing doesn't
make a lot of sense when you're not
addressing the [ __ ] problem of people
going in debt cause they're just gonna
accrue more debt
it doesn't make sense yeah i think the
cost of college is so high it's so
ridiculous it doesn't make sense
that needs to be addressed and when my
dad was young he paid through ucla right
like on a part-time job with them yeah
they would listen so people were able to
like like support themselves going to
school forever
yeah only in the last you know 15 years
that it's become so insane that it's
like yeah unimaginable i mean i went to
college in israel and i was able to work
and pay for myself right to go to
college right it's like yeah like um it
was i went to a community college and i
found that i got all i got everything i
needed there you know you know i'll tell
you something 2500 a semester i failed
out of i went to ucsc i failed out for a
year yeah i went to the community
college there for a year yeah and then i
could go back that was the deal we made
yeah i went there for a year
education i got from the community
college better better no it was better
literally i had classes with like 10
people no in many cases it is better i
was bonding with the teachers you know
in in santa cruz it's like here you're
in a [ __ ] auditorium with 500 people
right
i think not everyone should be going can
i get a deal yeah a lot of people don't
need shouldn't be going to college
because
don't i get a groupon for 500 people
saying you should do it i mean it's it's
like going to a concert avery has 240
thousand what what [ __ ] dude
what is it what are these oh my god wait
wait avery what are you doing tell us
about that he's our mod he ain't paying
that back with his salary
he has another job okay good
yeah
still film school what the [ __ ] no
that's crazy what cool avery a little
bit of that's on you
240
[Music]
avery did no one grab you and say let's
sit down
wow
yeah but you know at the same time
people go
college isn't for everyone
i think everyone should have access to
everyone should be able to get to higher
education
and you know for a lot of middle class
or even lower economic people the dream
part of the american dream is our kids
go to college absolutely it's it's
absolutely ingrained in our society i
just think that you know now it's like
you know what they do in germany is they
do have like uh a system where like
certain people will go to college
certain people won't i do think that
we've glamorized the idea of certain
professions and those don't always pay a
lot of money so this idea that everybody
wants to be some everyone wants to be in
the opinion business or everybody wants
to be
like some everyone's job needs to excite
them or make them really really happy
and you go a lot of people had great
lives where their job was just their job
they made a good living and then their
family their community their hobbies
made them happy i don't i don't think we
should search for fulfillment in every
single and i think that's kind of by
pushing that people take massively
expensive loan programs to to live their
dreams
and then the reality is is not everybody
arrives at those dreams right so i think
part of it is like getting realistic
yeah i don't know yeah i think you know
go ahead i don't know because i feel
like i worked at
those jobs that don't fulfill you yes
and i felt like i'm wasting my life away
i know but you are talented and
intelligent many people are not and they
are going to have to waste their
lives unfortunate i think there's
nothing wrong with accepting like the oh
i'm just like
99.9 percent of everyone else the
happiest people i know
are gym teachers in long island who went
to the capitol riot
they are that they are the happiest
people because they save up for that one
trip a year
okay
they have that one trippy into dc
and they are and they're and you know
they they throw volleyballs it's kids
heads or whatever yeah it's a great job
yeah yeah it is and um
but yeah i don't know i mean it's a good
thing i guess i am happy about it but
let's let's watch let's watch sloppy joe
here
that was my name and it never took off
sloppy joe like your yeah it works and
it never it never happened no no no what
do they call them what's his name again
sleepy joe which is not better yeah or
joe brandon
oh let's go bragging
joe brandt is the craziest thing have
you
brandon for themselves oh interesting
and he's dark brandon pull some of those
it's a mature country
i love the dark brandon
we are taking it back
yeah let me see some dark brandon um
you want the the edit that are oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
the best example but people i mean the
whole brandon phenomenon is really
something isn't it yeah
it's it's odd that people love those
catchphrases
and that will substitute so much else
they'll just go this it makes them feel
good so to me if it makes you feel good
god bless
but it's crazy to me that yelling at
anything will make you feel good but
here's the dark brandon saga from the
lives and i think this is great i love
what they're doing they're reclaiming it
oh [ __ ] look at this thread marlar
malarkey will not go and check jack
look at that that's just look at this i
mean our lord and savior dark brandon he
looks like is that vigor the carpathian
from it looks sure looks like it don't
stare at him in the eyes that's right
wait where's the edit
look at this
you've misunderstood you're in here with
me porn pop it's dark branson nz
yeah i love it shut up
brandon
excuse me
yeah so let's watch this
hey folks i want to hey folks right for
me we put out a plan to bring yeah so
every time there's a cut yeah he's
resting i like when he goes i want you
to hear it from me that's my favorite
one i could hear it from me
jack
relief to millions of working and
middle-class people with student loans
here's what you should know we're going
to forgive ten thousand dollars of
federal student loan debt keeping my
campaign promise for the people who need
to help the most the folks who went to
school on pell grants we're going to
forgive total of 20 000
we're going to target this relief help
is going to go to people making less
than 125 000 a year next we're going to
give anyone undergraduate loans a chance
to sign up and cap your loan payments at
five percent of your monthly income
that's that oh that's great if you're
making over buck 25 and you live in a
place like new york or alex it's not
great it's not right right and it's no
you're not rich right yeah that cap is
so arbitrary it's a weird arbitrary cap
i mean even like this avery situation i
don't know what he's making but he went
to film school so he's probably pretty
capable of making a pretty decent income
yeah right like it could make 125 but
covering 240 in debt it's yeah that will
take help people if you're gonna help
them i mean you could raise it maybe to
250 but then the people be like oh what
the [ __ ] people have no conception of
how much it actually cost and i live in
big cities who don't right you hear 125
you're like bro you're set for life yeah
yeah it's right there you're like middle
class yeah for sure
anyway brandon um
yeah i like i like how they
is this what is this people that are
finding out that they're yeah they're
having a beautiful moment yeah they're
having a they're like she's showing him
like hey
we only owe 218 thousand dollars
i've got some good news to be honest he
doesn't look that relieved you know that
soul-crushing debt it's gone by 10
yeah it's gone yeah right by ten
thousand we only owe 158 thousand
dollars but this is actually a good
thing here i think this is where they'll
really help people cap your loan at five
percent of your monthly income so if
you're a guy yeah like avery or anyone
right kind of work just working five
percent
cap it how long and then [ __ ] them you
know how long is it for until he's out
of office like when they say
yeah
he made it sound like it's indefinite
but yeah five percent of your monthly
income right and if trump could yeah
minus ten yeah
yeah
ron desantis could come in and be like
listen yeah gays pay more yeah
if you say it
it's a weird it's a weird thing student
loans because there are a lot of people
that didn't go to college that go why am
i subsidizing this yeah and i didn't go
to college i get that yeah but ideally
we should be subsidizing it anyway well
sure i mean we should be helping people
we should never have let it get here
yeah no and we got to address those uh
situations absolutely [ __ ] but yeah
if we cut a little bit of that defense
budget
we could you know
just a little bit you shave a little
time slipper off the top sliver off the
top
free student and you could easily live
off the top no homelessness you could
easily well you'd still have some but
you wouldn't be nearly as much they'd be
like no we need the 10 trillion yeah can
we can we just get one percent of that
yeah absolutely not they should biden
should come out next and say he's taking
10 homeless people and giving them
houses oh that would be great yeah he
goes just a rule of ten
take ten thousand off
debt and we give 10 homeless families
houses
for a year and then yeah yeah yeah right
and we figure it out until the next day
comes your monthly income i also want to
make sure folks have enough time to
transition back to pain regularly so
we're going to extend the student loan
pause one final time after december 31st
of this year there's a lot more here
more than i have time to say in this
video but i got it's time for my nap
because there's a lot more here and most
of it isn't great
yeah it's 58 minutes joe biden right how
do you not have time to talk about more
oh it's 58 or 50
one minute being coherent a day yeah
yeah i only have one minute jack and
it's nap time
i don't have much time left
i gotta enjoy every minute folks
through december 31st of this year
there's a lot more here more than i have
time to say [ __ ] how busy are
you 58 seconds
yeah well i don't know that he knows
what what else is in here
because there's more here so they tell
me
i'll tell you about it another time yeah
this video but i'll leave you with this
our middle class families deserve
breathing room
it's the whole reason i ran but i'll
leave you with this yeah i once owned a
horse
long hairs
the kids would come and play on that
horse it's like well what that was the
first steak
yeah he's so old i hate i i've been
ranting about this yeah
i have a problem
with the the the geriatric i mean the
it's a there's a name for it
gerontocracy yes our country is run by
old people well a lot of them don't want
to leave office right because they don't
pass the baton they don't want to pass
the baton this is their status god only
knows if they've committed crimes in
office and people will look into that
right they have so it's like one of the
reasons you don't want to not you know
so yeah i mean there's just some weird
stuff but a lot of young people don't
want these jobs and the ones who do are
insane yeah i think they do i think
young people do want the job as well
it's hard it's hard to you know take
nancy pelosi's job when you're some
random sure but young people say to
themselves okay i could go into tech i
could go into whatever yeah i could make
money i could live a private life or i
could get ripped apart every day rip to
shreds yeah it's my my safety whatever
yeah you know you know and it just get
you know it's not an attractive job it's
so tough it's so tough and then also
everybody knows it's so hard to get
stuff done
i mean look at aoc as an example yeah
the amount just that she deals with on a
day-to-day basis i don't know how she
manages to get through life
but she seems to like it too like and
that's part of the it's a personality
type that wants it right sure there's a
personality type of people that can
withstand it and kind of excludes a lot
of good people well it excludes a lot of
people who are actually you know
focusing on issues and understand issues
like you know it's got to be people that
want to live in the public light in the
spotlight to a degree and then you know
and not that she doesn't get abused but
like some of it is like she dishes it
she takes it she's this is
crap she's scratching she's scrapped
which is
i think she's got to be yeah she'll be
able to do what nobody can do her
position
is going to get anywhere by being a
policy wonk no one's going to get
anywhere sitting in a room looking at
numbers going here's what i figured out
they have to be on the chat circuit
they're all selling books they're all on
jimmy kimmel they're all enemies you
know they're they're they're building a
brand it's a celebrity thing really it's
a celebrity thing so just in case they
don't solve homelessness you know on the
off chance there's a good they get to
anyway jill what were you saying
this plan will give opportunity to
millions of families who need it the
most
hey folks hey folks flew an airplane
wants if paper made a kid cry
good kid though his mom's name was
cheryl cut her grass
beautiful hair you smelled it
maybelline
anyway ten thousand dollars
i love girl though
i love joe it's crazy that i've seen his
son's dick
oh interesting yes online online yeah
not in person
[Laughter]
yeah
that might be the first time in history
you could say that about a president's
son yeah interesting yeah that's a good
point his son's a wild guy
from what i hear
kind of
kind of living his best life well he's
certainly a guy who
you'd you'd go this should be a movie
right like he's
you know was dating his dead brother's
wife interesting going all over the
world that's a little dicey the one that
died of brain cancer yes he was dating
her he was oh yeah wait wait what
like shortly after he died yeah why it
is a loose definition of his best life
uh
it is but yeah he was doing that no
here's the thing about him he's not the
most moral guy
well he's like
he likes to smoke crack it is the crack
in the hookers and the hookers and the
hookers and stuff and maybe some shady
financial dealings and he's maybe
getting kickbacks from foreign
government could be
best life it's a fun but at least he's
honest about it you know jared kushner
yes don jr i like it out in the office
exactly i want to see jared kushner's
dick
or don junior's at least everything yeah
yeah yeah and but do you want to see
that
jared kushner i think he's a little bit
of a cutie and you do uh yeah aaron
trump not just so much for me but he's
not introduced in the middle
yeah
he's a harry potter character kushner i
like it he's a slave
yeah he's tall i mean guess yeah he's
tall
my friend saw him at like a he was at
some type of
yeah there's something nice about that
he doesn't have any blood in his skin
i like that it's nice
i like that i think it's nice you know
jared kushner's dad paid money to set up
i believe his own brother with like a
prostitute i mean they're just fun
people
you know he's a fun group his dad is
[ __ ] nuts nuts his dad is like a real
psycho like yeah like a real like read
me some of the [ __ ] his dad's done dan
because it's real interesting
yeah the kush the cush i like to smoke
the kush the big kush
hey i'll get on my knees and smoke that
kush
he's a
yeah he's he looks like a like a like a
a vampire he does he's like a like a
like a you remember that bat that band
called badly drawn boy
that was a band and that's feels like
that badly drawn boy yeah they were like
a band
i think they were like a one-hit wonder
so and that's what it feels like with
kind of kushner that guy's got a lot
more life in his skin
but the emoji yeah no i just mean like
kushner is a badly drawn boy oh okay
yeah but they don't look alive yeah okay
what dan what'd you find on the kush his
dad uh yeah i've forgotten about this
story yeah his dad went to jail for
amongst other things he was doing some
you know king lear [ __ ] basically yeah
he hired a prostitute he knew to seduce
his brother-in-law and arrange to record
a sexual encounter between the two
and had the tape sent to his sister oh
my god
sentenced to two years in prison he
served 14 months in federal law
alabama um i believe it is illegal
prostitution is illegal blackmail's
illegal
i got to throw up you gotta call your
lawyers real quick there's like seven
felonies yeah
that's not good
but
yeah and he and and yeah and you're like
this is and you're in the white house
you go wow because they have a lot of
money my point is yeah he's a good
people that's right my point is is at
least hunter he's just giving his laptop
to anyone who wants it
yeah hunter certainly has not been as uh
you know you know uh
he's not been as secretive no as other
people in his position he's been quite
open but you know this guy like
he's an interesting guy my friend saw
him at
a trump club and he was in the pool with
ivanka he was like uh and my friend goes
in the pool i found that yeah my friend
said he was very pale well yeah yeah
lots of sunscreen very pale makes sense
he the fact that he went in the pool is
very surprising to me yeah is he a shirt
on guy no shirt off
kind of thin pale wave
and he just kind of went in and they
have children i guess is this right
hunter biden's icloud password was one
two three four
no i'm just making a joke
because you never know
thanks jb gonna [ __ ] do me again like
that i was trying to serve you he was he
was uh he was serving you up online you
dropped the ball thank you bro
i thought that was a real factoid it's
believable plausible yeah
um fox news by the way is celebrating
the long this is on their their front
page which is kind of dope fun
it's not that bad this is the front page
of fox's website yeah this is the front
page of fox news kind of fun
oh with the yeah yeah
it doesn't make him look bad i mean he's
making it rain yeah this is where they
this is not one of the issues that
they're particularly good at and popular
with
yeah this is this is where there's a
small group of billionaires that push
some of those things that this is not
like most people are like okay yeah give
us money
it's never like a good right not a huge
well the whole college debt forgiveness
thing if i'm right is
wildly unpopular actually well here's
the thing it's there's a lot of people
that feel like i made certain decisions
why should i
have to subsidize other people's
decisions or irresponsibility or
whatever
part of that is because we haven't fixed
any of the other issues right so people
that are in health in soul-crushing debt
or healthcare
they're looking at this maybe and going
well why did they get
but what's important to tell those
people is that this is only ten thousand
dollars it doesn't really help anyone so
that's what i would say that's what i
think the white house should go out and
say listen anyone who's upset at this
realize it doesn't do anything nothing
and the people that are really in
trouble will still continue to be in
trouble don't worry about it you'll all
be involved together
don't worry about it love that and that
i think will bring people together that
is a uniting message yeah what about so
nancy pelosi you know
like uh subsidizing things is normal we
we do that for a lot of stuff yes but i
think for people who say that they might
be unaware that it's already happening
for other things too
we're very selfish country people within
it
so you know and i get it because people
go hey i want
my thing to be helped and then if they
help another thing they go hey what if
my kid has cancer yes that's part of
it's just so weird because i think what
you're saying is like you know corn just
the [ __ ] corn industry yeah like
like ungodly amounts of money
why are we why are we is because the
government
you know fannie mae and freddie mac are
these government sponsored entities that
implicitly guarantee mortgage loans
that's why we have a 30-year fix more i
mean the government's been involved in
everything yeah and people that don't
know that are ignorant but i do think
there's also like people go well
one group gets helped i want to be
helped as well yeah and they should
actually the problem is yeah and they're
right somewhere right yeah
and that's the problem of you know
living a country of selfish people is
that
sometimes helping other people helps you
it helps everybody sure it does i mean
people complain about homelessness they
complain about shootings it it's all
connected you own a business people
the country
is yeah
it's the health of the country is not
phenomenal at the moment it doesn't feel
like it doesn't feel great yeah but i i
can't decide if it's like that bad
because everyone always says oh or the
world's gonna end it could be worse yeah
that's what you always have to remember
it could be worse to me abortions being
illegal is just like that's not i can't
get past that i feel like that's so they
are illegal in a lot of places what was
interesting is kansas just had a vote
and they kept it yeah that was kansas is
a red state right i think that
that's an issue that
there's report there's issues where
republicans are strong on with voters
and we i think abortion's actually gonna
be one of them where it's they're weaker
they're gonna get crushed
so because they're pushing for like a
national
yeah they're not gonna get it they won't
get a national ban i mean we thought
they wouldn't get
removed no for sure but they won't get a
national ban that would be no way
they'll get that a national ban would be
like war yeah and i also don't think
they'll get
a lot of these states i think will be
more resilient than they imagine like i
think a lot of them will vote to keep
abortion within a certain parameter i
really hope so and another thing that i
was just listening to that made me
really scared is that there's a lot of
extremists out there that are pushing
for
getting the women also punished for
homicide when they do get an impression
that's that's
so crazy
the person yeah like this person who's
uh who's like campaigning for it yeah he
has like three hundred thousand
subscribers on youtube yeah you know
like it's legit like these people are
heard absolutely
they got this bill like actually
discussed yes you know and voted for it
it's real women who are having an
abortion or homicide and and like in
some in some states it would be like
death penalty and the guy's like yes
that's pro-life yeah
that's pro-life yeah that's an important
woman's death yeah there's something fun
about that
because then you would put the woman to
death and still be pro-life well what's
fun is yeah exactly yeah well yeah i
think that's fantastic well it's a very
interesting thing it's a transitive
property of life yeah it's a very
interesting thing
two for a pro-life thing then have the
general woman with a death champion yeah
but that's but here's here's a real
answer get dual citizenship
yeah i have that actually yeah if you
can
if anyone although i got to be honest
i have we have both dual citizenship i'm
not super excited about
our backup isn't like the best backup
ever in the in the instance of global
destabilization mine will be israel my
mother was born in ireland i'm trying to
get irish city that's good you'll find
nobody [ __ ] with you there there's not
going to be a war they'll be the last
people to even know there was something
going on
yeah but can you imagine that the glow a
global destabilization war yeah chaos
i'm going to israel yeah
yeah it's not exactly a chill place yeah
that's going to be tough yeah but at the
same time world war z israel was the
only country that uh could withstand the
zombie apocalypse so maybe it would be
the best place yeah who produced that
movie you can have abortions in israel
who did produce them yeah curious
[Laughter]
what i just said in israel you can have
abortions
jewish
world war z oh thank you
i think in america that uh these things
would you like to do like a hammer guy
thank you max brooks is he jewish
um
i will get back to you on that let me
see i'll find the details i mean i would
imagine i i don't know i mean
a lot of people think about israel yeah
that aren't jewish
that's true christians love it they
[ __ ] love it they love israel and
it's so cool i love their theory yeah
which is what they all the jews will die
when jesus comes back is that their
theory yeah that's why they love it
according to their fun theory
according to their prophecy the jews are
meant to hold the land yeah until jesus
returns in which obviously he'll banish
them all to hell right and then they get
israel
it's very interesting how people see
this all playing out
you know
but it keeps people going these beliefs
keep people going
uh keeps you doing whatever you have to
do keeps you going to the office
yeah so
it's an odd thing to motivate you
you know
yeah i'm in traffic now
but one day
jesus will come back and you know damn
the jews to hell and it'll be okay
lighten the traffic a little bit yeah
yeah that's interesting well when the
rapture comes they apparently ascend to
heaven yes yes they i believe that they
will lose that they can take their cars
with them no they go right to heaven
um austin they go right to austin
yeah this is a great story dude nancy
pelosi is one of my most loathed
politicians i [ __ ] i'm a die-hard lib
and i vote democrat every [ __ ] time
i'm not loving the democrats but you
know it's better in my opinion nancy
pelosi is an actual [ __ ] demon
and i love that her husband
five days five days for a dui i mean i'm
surprised this man
did any time
now is that a five oh my god walk them
through and then walk them out you're
gonna love this yeah the author of that
bro that book yeah this isn't good right
you sure about that amy before i say
this
i'm trying to confirm it keeps leading
me to the same thing yeah what book
world world boys oh yeah it's max brooks
it's mel brook's son yes
you know that i did not know that
i didn't know very jewish interesting
[Laughter]
i'm shocked
there's nothing wrong with saying hey
we're gonna make a zombie movie where my
people
wrong with win at all
but as an irish guy like no we would
never
write a book where we died first because
no one would believe that ireland like
was stood the zombies
yeah so
uh nancy pelosi
you got a dewey five days in jail
don't you think it's interesting that
she can work something for him and i'm
sure she just wouldn't care about it
yeah what's interesting about her is
that this is probably one of those
situations where
she's like you to do five right we've
been outside of trading for 30 [ __ ]
years yeah yeah we have things going on
people i mean we should but she she's
probably looking at him at dinner going
we should both be in jail for like
multiple life sentences right so just do
five you know you that might be right
just toss them a bone yeah she's like
listen you gotta do five
you know what we've done
and then he just like silently nods he's
eating some chilean sea bass you know
something soft he silently nods and she
goes you just gotta do five and you know
what is really five is five just they
walk him in and walk him out because by
the way
jail sentences under five days a lot of
them are fake because the jail will go
we're not doing this whole checking you
in
it's a walkthrough you sit there for two
hours and you leave it's ceremonial and
i know several people that it's happened
to because by the time they get you in
makes sense why are they bothered
yeah yeah
30 years
30 years makes stealing at snickers yeah
that's good that's okay he'll get
involved there by the way i'm just going
to say
this is a friend of the show yeah i just
wish that nancy pelosi's husband he
clear got the right attorney uh this is
the this guy's specialized he could have
got him all right lately
yeah check it out all right
this is my man we're right outside of
van nuys courthouse i got my great
client here he was charged with a second
time dui
uh he admittedly overdosed on multiple
different drugs that night it caused a
drug induced psychosis he crashed with
two other cars on a freeway and flipped
over a few times luckily everyone made
it out all right
um the fire department came with the
police used the jaws of life dragged him
out of the car and started fighting with
them they charged him with resisting
arrest also
um
and we're pleased to announce that he's
getting out of this with just a wet
reckless reckless driving one year of
probation not five years that is
normally given in a second time dui and
most importantly he's really changed his
life around my favorite is this guy
being like i did this by the way this is
this is amazing
it's an amazing country people say
things aren't good things are fine this
is one of the best videos ever things
are good i mean this is truly amazing
yeah so he ends every video with the
catchphrase he put himself in rehab
immediately after this happened he's
been in for nine months he does meetings
every single day and he's really turned
his life around how you feeling i'm
feeling great thank you so much david
for everything i've done
all right
oh what's his catchphrase usually let's
go
every single video except this one
apparently yeah but actually vehicular
manslaughter let's go
and so
this guy actually called in the show
he's a friend of the show actually a
good guy interesting guy good lawyer
yeah yeah you gotta listen he he gave us
good advice and sometimes you have to
help them but he told us if you ever
are driving drunk right and you crash
yes
you think oh don't leave the scene no
leave this scene immediately that's what
he says he goes leave the scene because
they can't prove you're drunk now of
course my friend did that you knew about
that the next day oh my god and he went
yeah i must have hit my head i like
stumbled out i was like i don't know
what happened and they go listen we knew
you were drunk there's nothing we can do
about it wow um but that's absolutely
true no here's a real i didn't know
about that you should leave the scene of
most accidents oh my god most it's a
horrible way to meet anyone right
yeah it's very bad it's much better to
online first i think i would go if you
can leave go if you can leave i got in
one accident once it was a fender bender
it was a big fat woman from long island
she got out and she started screaming at
me and i just said let me get out of
here and i just left
she was fine she's not hurt
oh that's a serious problem you know
it's time it's how you look at it
but i don't think like compared to no
it's not that big i'm not talking
morally there's so many reasons you
could you had to leave
there's so many you were confused you
were disoriented
you didn't know what happened right this
idea that you were in control is crazy
i'm not in control right now who knows
why we do what we do right and i think
that's what it is but i i'm a big fan of
like
immediately after the accident
assessed do you need to be there
that's so interesting you already hear
guys from tin dylan because you said
that he'll run yeah no at tim dylan on
twitter
but you could someone could kill you
you're absolutely people are [ __ ]
someone could kill you right if you stay
connected with yourself it's my
obligation back hit and run connect with
them later on social
yeah we're morally obligated to hit yes
and run well the reality is once
the damage has been done what are you
gonna do yeah are you a doctor no no no
so just head out of there and someone
will have the jaws
don't call do i do you leave your info
no no no
no no no no no no you have to do that
i've never been in a car accident so i
don't even know here's the deal a lot of
people like privacy and i think we're a
country now that's gotten away from that
um but i i i look at it like you know
you're a vpn
this is interesting i love you actually
works with nancy pelosi
wait domestic violence okay she looks
man right there by the way
what does she do a domestic violence
yeah oh does he do it with domestic
violence yeah dude can you guys pull up
some other ones because this guy's my
favorite person
no he's my i want to go out to a
corporate steakhouse with him
and he will do i'm telling you he we had
him call in yeah and we were expecting
this no but he's probably yeah everybody
loved him right
yeah
this man i love the comments of this no
keep this van off the road for life i
love this bro unleashing super villain
yeah and look he replied laughing yeah
he laughed yeah
he loves it well you know what it is we
all know defense attorneys are supposed
to be they're supposed to have a
personality all the big defense
attorneys in new york city used to
defend the mob or whatever like they
were all kind of colorful characters and
you know this is part of it
yes so
um what's
what's interesting here
is that dude all of this this has to be
satire nope i document real cases you
don't see on tv what's interesting
i said how do you get them to do this
because it's humiliating for them yeah
this video is going viral this man is
gonna get he's gonna cause a lot of
real-life problems
and he says i just i just
i just hit him with it i don't warn him
right i ask i just open the phone and he
does it and then they don't know what to
do yeah it's already wrong
it's smart here's the thing some people
might look at it and create it's a hit
and run but here's a it's a great
marketing thing because there are people
watching this who are criminals and need
representation
i'll tell you what man
if i ever gotten a hit and run or drunk
or something i'm not calling my [ __ ]
no big wig expensive attorney call this
guy who works out of his car in van nuys
here's another one there's so many good
ones man
i'm glad you've already all right we're
right outside of the court in downtown
l.a with mike it says two domestic
violence cases consolidated
result trespassing
all right we're right outside of court
in downtown l.a with my great client
here it was falsely alleged against him
that he committed domestic violence
against the mother of his child on one
day and it was also falsely alleged
again that he did it two and a half
months later this was two domestic
violence cases consolidated into one
and we just resolved the case what did
we resolve it for what was the the
conviction trespass
trespassing
say it louder is that [ __ ] great
that's right we were fighting this case
for about seven to eight months we
announced ready for trial on this case
we're ready to go forward and beat the
charges and i'm pleased to announce that
once once he's done with probation it's
going to be gone off his record once we
expunge it
how you feel feels great appreciate it i
feel great i'm gonna go beat the [ __ ]
out of my wife
yeah i'm gonna do it again wow
let's go
it's crazy but yeah good attorney right
it's a great attorney yeah because
that's what you want you want an
attorney who's getting uh multiple
assaults knocked down to trespassing
right yeah i mean that's what you
ideally want
if you are assaulting people multiple
times
i mean that's now there's other people
who will have oh here here's a here's a
favorite
i'll show you this one
all right we're right outside of santa
clarita courthouse
uh where we just got an amazing deal on
a case
my amazing client here was charged with
uh committing an act of violence towards
a minor
while we
it's like it's already great it's
amazing
i disagree with that and we feel like i
love that they don't say it's false they
just so we disagree with disagreed
you can't even say he didn't a
divergence of opinion
towards a minor like it happened
different than what yeah the kids said
yeah well we
disagree with that and we feel like it
didn't happen the way that it was
alleged we got an amazing deal where
after just a little bit of community
service case will be dismissed how do
you feel
i feel amazing man you guys did a
wonderful job man i appreciate you guys
going to bat for me and let the facts
show that you know i didn't do what the
alleged i did so i appreciate it i love
how he goes i didn't do it but he's like
it didn't happen i love the word
wonderful being used outside of like
family court yeah you did a wonderful
job
i'm happy to be here
i didn't hit the child the way they said
i did it didn't happen like yeah thank
you for clarifying your honor the child
yeah
oh man interesting is this great this
guy's a lot of fun he's great oh thank
you
let's go let's go
yeah there's one where he's like my
great client here crashed his car into a
house he was drunk fled the scene he hit
a police officer's car on the way that's
the best thing
it's just it's like i got his he's uh
he's no sentence or yeah wet and
reckless or some [ __ ]
you see that one it's really amazing
that uh but it works right i mean people
probably probably gets a lot of clients
from this
right we just got out of control what
was interesting he says i'm not really
doing that anymore he's doing elder
abuse now oh he's doing elder abuse so
so he's making videos where he's like my
client worked in a nursing home they
said he hit this woman in the face
he did not like financial crimes oh
interesting yeah people that rip off the
elderly he's defending them
she should have known what that contract
meant
right good yeah yeah well he's doing a
good thing he's a sweetheart here here's
one more
this one's good
second time dui alcohol and cocaine
zero jail four in beautiful newport
beach we're here on a second time dui my
great client here
uh was pulled over he had doubled the
legal limit he was actually at .18 blood
alcohol content he had 13 nanograms of
cocaine in his blood they found an
empty vinyl i love how he just
aaron
yeah for the world
he's like man i was kind of hoping to
like
not talk about this [ __ ] cane in his
blood
they found an
empty vial of that also
uh he was looking at 150 days of county
jail out here
and we just crushed it he's gonna do how
much jail from none
zero jail
zero jail
and after a year he's going to be all
done with this case and he can move on
with his life yeah thank you so much i
appreciate the the help
and the work that's put in
[Applause]
it's amazing it's really like truly yeah
inspires my faith enp is the name of his
sperm it's inspiring stuff
i'm glad you like god bless
um so let's see nancy pelosi is a witch
um pnp
sleepy joe
watching that makes you lego oh maybe i
should have went to law school you know
because he believes the guy believes in
what he's doing yeah he does it's rare
that he actually does he really does
he's like this guy's gonna change
you know no jail time he doesn't need it
he's back out on the street reforming
himself yeah
um
so
okay let's talk about this one
you ready for this one i don't even know
okay
i know what you did next no i'm just
kidding it's not about that
uh andrew tate i want to talk to you
about yes
yes so
is he banned him on everything he's
banned on everything
i know you didn't love that i love it
well yes i know that you love it but i i
just worry about
you know
number one is he that
crazy that you would ban him
yes yes actually i have clips because i
wanted to persuade you i okay you don't
need to agree with me for sure in my
opinion i'm always
reluctant to ban anyone
right because yeah and i think honestly
i gotta say yeah because a lot of people
go oh well they're going to ban him
they're going to start banning everybody
right there but the people who have been
truly deeply platformed yeah kind of
deserved it i don't know much about i
know he says a lot of wild stuff i
haven't heard anything where i'd go
he should be
banished
yeah okay well here let's see i mean
you've
let's see um
i know you've seen a lot of these ones
because i saw you talking about it in
your clip oh this video is not available
yeah a lot of these are just too insane
to put on what is he saying that is
there's a video of him beating but um
he's saying stuff like that
women are the
property of their
boyfriend or husband whatever it is you
saying is
okay which i disagree with
clearly um that being said
is
when he is saying that
have are we going to ban every religious
person on youtube that says something
that's very similar to that right i
think ultimately what he advocates is
for violence against women yes okay so i
haven't seen no he's been he's bro
okay he's has videos of him saying like
if i catch my woman cheating i think you
saw that cause he referenced it well i
think there's one of the things you said
oh he's joking he's not well he said if
she came at me with a machete i think
the full context of that because people
were correcting me let me on the line
there was a new link okay the full
contacts was she was saying
yeah if she grabbed the machete he'd
grab a machete or something like that
yeah let's watch
dude once said to me
you think so yeah well just don't show
it i'll just show it to tim you guys can
hear the audio he's a big ass [ __ ]
knife what if you like upset a girl and
she catches you cheating and gets a
machete
there's no female alive
even with a machete
that would stand a chance against the
immense power i possess
have you ever seen a woman try and do
anything complicated
like imagine a girl pick this up if i
pick this up
you ain't [ __ ] with me but i'm a
left-hander i'd still like jab i'd
[ __ ] swing low take your [ __ ] knee
out you're
and again i'm not saying he should be
like a senator right right go ahead
if you take into context also that he's
done sex trafficking does it change your
well listen
one hundred percent if he's doing sex
trafficking and that is
yeah well i mean listen if that that
needs to be handled by authorities i
mean that's beyond the scope of youtube
yeah no i yeah of course and and yeah i
mean that's the embassy
he's no so what do you think i'm gonna
be like well that's not a big no
even if you think that maybe that video
was just trolling yeah like knowing the
full scope of who the guy is kind of
doing that he's right
it's 100
not it's a he that's a legal issue it's
not essential oh yeah here's my take
i think in the totality of his
work and the influence he's having yeah
he is recruiting
men and encouraging violence and control
of women now here's where i see it right
i think a lot of people see it
differently yeah so we're talking about
censorship we're talking about freedom
of speech yeah everybody believes in and
censorship it's just a matter of where
you draw the line sure do you think for
example isis should be able to have a
tick tock
what are they doing is it they're just
talking about they're dancing then yes
they're radicalizing people they're
talking about like infidels and we need
to stone infidels
you might come to you you know if you
don't join us you're gonna go to hell
but you might have to delete a lot more
channels than isis if you were going to
apply a very broad definition but that
doesn't happen well let's just what i
mean here's the thing there's a lot of
clerics islamic clerics that are in the
uk that say very similar things to that
right on tick tock
probably i mean i you could easily pull
up ten inches
let me just
yeah i don't think they should be
allowed to do that yeah because it's
hate speech right
well it depends on what they're saying i
think it's the hate speech think it's
very blurry right yeah because like if
you criticize
certain uh people
in you know
a war for example right
you there's you know for example they
allowed
the social media companies allowed
people to say things about russian
people not only putin they were able to
say hateful things about russian people
during the onset of the russia ukraine
war they were they were kind of allowing
some more of that stuff right so i think
it's really that these wait
you're saying you couldn't support
russia no you could say anything you
wanted to about russia you could say
kill all rush you could say all that
stuff i think a lot of these standards
are unevenly applied because it's very
difficult to apply standards evenly how
is it
i'm confused about what were people
being censored about in the ukraine no
they weren't they weren't for example
you were saying if there's if there's
hate speech and you go what constitutes
that because
it's it's it's i think what causes that
is you know calling for violence
or or
yeah violence against you know i think
harassment for example doxxing and
harassment targeted harassment of people
and boxing are very easy to identify and
shouldn't be tolerated but people saying
hateful things about each other or it's
more about targeting a group of people
right sure so yeah
also like let's acknowledge that these
are private companies it's not they can
do whatever they want not a free even
really
no they can absolutely do whatever they
want the government owned twitter it'd
be a whole different conversation
but where i actually agree with them is
that so i personally think if isis was
doing like the sprite challenge on tick
tock i wouldn't be down with that for
sure because ultimately their goal is to
radicalize people
yeah and ultimately you know kill people
like me right or and lots of other
people everyone that's not them
and then so let's take it a little bit
further do you think that like um
like uh the kkk or like ultra white
nationalists should be able to have uh a
tick tock or youtube channel where they
i think probably and the reason i say
that is because
i think if you if you in like we dealt
with the kkk for many years by ignoring
them right kkk they're they're able to
march they're able to speak this is
something the supreme court ruled on
um yeah that's free speech yeah that's
not what we're talking about i mean if
tick tock wants to ban their channel
i don't as a private company they can do
whatever they want if you ask me should
people with horrible views be allowed on
social media i would say yes because i
think that you need to counter those
with better views i think there's a
difference between
bad views yeah
and like dangerous views like great and
by the way yes this whole that's true
and the whole like notion of like the
battle of ideas or whatever good good
ideas be bad ideas i think we've learned
that that that's not really happening is
it well on the internet well it doesn't
really happen well it doesn't happen
because these algorithms of these
companies are designed to reward
negativity right they're designed to
reward certain things and not reward
other things but i think that the thing
is when rt gets deleted that's probably
why they even see it more paramount
but like when rt gets deleted from
youtube and you have people like chris
hedges who's anti-war correspondent or
abby martin or people like that their
entire library of work gets deleted um
and you know there are people that don't
like them there are people that but
they're not engaging in hate speech per
se yeah and i feel like you know
anything
they're just you know chris hedge is a
war
correspondent why was his channel well
it was just part of rt right so they
just deleted this entire like russian
propaganda well it wasn't that's what
they said well it's a network that's not
american right so it's like anti it's
not an american network per se but you
have his entire library of content that
gets deleted with that my thing is who
makes these
decisions like these are all
unaccountable people that work at these
companies that are making these
decisions is there any process that
could be more democratic more
transparent where that the banning is
not just an edict of a small group of
people is there a way to do it that
might well they'll never it would have
to be owned by the you know the
government for that to ever be a thing
there there's no incentive for them to
to do anything not opaquely right so i
just wonder i i don't know what
i just wonder what's the big fear yeah
what are you what are you doing
always that for example people are
getting kicked off twitter in the
beginning of covet for saying that kovid
may have originated in a lab now that is
a a
belief that's been in the mainstream
media
so
there was a difference right at the time
it was like
there was literally no evidence to
support that that's untrue that's not
true i think it is there were doctors
saying that this is a manipulated virus
they're saying it's producing effects
that they've never seen before and even
if there was no evidence to support it
they ended up being right some doctors
were saying it was manipulated yeah but
i mean the vast majority of experts were
saying there's no reason to believe but
to delete someone was created in a lab
now there's i don't know the vast
majority of experts i don't see
themselves on a lot i just want to be i
just want to be clear i don't think
people were getting banned just for
saying i think this originated in china
i don't know i think people are getting
banned for like outright uh like hateful
[ __ ] like calling it like kung flu and
saying we need to [ __ ] there's
there's people that get to a degree that
is inciting hate and violence against
asian people yeah that was a problem so
i don't think people were really getting
banned but there were injuries people
that have been banned for
certain things where you go these are
now accepted things or they're now
mainstream beliefs right but you have to
draw the difference right because yeah
people like people you could say i think
this originated in china right now get
banned yeah this is the people that
during a time when asian people were
being [ __ ] uh berenstain's a guy who
just got kicked off twitter he actually
won a court case he just got put back on
he's a big critic of the vaccine right
you just actually won a court case part
of my thing here is like should we be
giving the people that run tech
companies complete and total authority
and power over the public domain and i
think that we can all find egregious
examples of people that say very
offensive things we go yes they
shouldn't have a platform that being
said we don't i don't know that this is
a st when you say like what is everyone
afraid of i think people like me that
make a living speaking or whatever i
don't think we're completely comfortable
with giving
private tech companies complete control
over the public but you're not saying
anything on the level of what he's
saying no no i'm not worried about
myself per se i'm just saying i'm
saying i don't know
where
things go and i think that there's
there's a certain
acknowledgement of the fact that like
small groups of people
making decisions for everybody
is not necessarily in the interest of
everybody right i mean it's throughout
history you've seen that like if you
have complete total power that might not
be good right i feel like so that's
where i just look at twitter and i go
this is a very small group of people
that have complete power true yeah
that's my that's my thing i feel like
that could be a solid thing to talk
about but yeah we can talk about it not
when we're talking about andrew tate
being removed because i don't think that
what you're talking about applies to
this guy who is just he's saying vile
stuff that i'm a woman you're not right
it doesn't affect you
so well it does in the sense that we all
live in a society i don't want to know
what i read no but it doesn't affect you
like it doesn't mean i'm a woman yeah he
hates me
yeah like you know what i mean it's like
jews and and the cake oh
that he arouses he says crazy things
yeah
what's interesting is that the amount of
people i see who are like free speech
let's not ban or a lot of the stuff i
say is i don't like tate but
uh you know i believe in not censoring
people in free speech it's all men right
it's all men if you talk it really is
there's got to be some women there
no i'm sure there's literally it's 100
from what i don't think educate has good
ideas i don't think his ideas are good
for young men what i think is there is a
a whole other problem about unilaterally
banning somebody the way these platforms
work together to ban somebody overnight
completely remove them not overnight i
well it may not be overnight but it's
not overnight
right i'm sure it's been debated for a
long time but that process
maybe should be a little bit more public
so do you think twitter should be
nationalized
i don't know if twitter should be
national because that's the only way
that's going to happen yeah but i i will
say this i mean he's already made it to
such stardom and like mainstream he's
been talked on everywhere so it took
them months to make it i think it's a
complex issue
it's not an easy issue i don't think
it's an easy fix i don't think any
anyone is saying it's easily solvable
is wrong because that basically you're
just saying whoever runs twitter and
youtube at the current moment should be
god that's a hard no oversight at all
that's a difficult argument to make two
different issues right like one issue
you're addressing
i think everyone agrees with people
there's a concentration of power and
these social medias yes that is they
have this unaccountable amount of power
that needs to be a conversation around
that yeah but at the same time i also
think that hate groups violent hate
groups
uh
should not be expected to have
uh free reigns i think they [ __ ] they
want to draw a line around violent hate
groups totally understand i think it is
a violent hate group
i don't know listen if you what he's
doing if it's human trafficking one
hundred percent that's there's no if
that's it yeah
i know nothing about that yeah
yeah we can set that aside yeah he also
does like his whole hustler universities
on like a pyramid scheme i i would never
tell anyone to join hustlers university
yeah okay there are so many pyramid
schemes and so many guys on youtube with
selling [ __ ] classes i want to
separate
i don't want to give him any benefit of
the doubt that maybe this is just a
troll he deserves that's why i'm dating
him is that is that okay
does that matter that is interesting
here's a reality he's gay and he hates
women no
listen i agree that a lot of what i've
heard him say is some of it's trolly and
funny where he's been when he says i
don't when he goes if i go and have sex
with a woman i don't love her it's not
cheating it's
exercise to me that seems like you're
making a joke yeah he's not but he's not
that's why i keep bringing these things
up because he's not a troll he's not a
comedian he's not he's like
big brother like it seems like he yeah
he was a while yeah i don't he got
kicked off and i don't know if you
thought if you saw those videos of the
teachers from school no i didn't see
that so kids are like refusing to listen
to a female teacher that's not their
refusal and they say we learned it from
dave using to read an essay that was
written by a female author yeah it's
great it's no that's crazy
that's crazy so that's like it's really
bad that's not good and there's got to
be
there's there's blame for that in more
places than andrew tape but absolutely
like
of course yes but sure but we don't have
to look everywhere around your butt you
know probably a lot of people but yeah i
don't think this is a guy who
um
has ideas that are helping the next
generation of men the question because
in the same way not helping
is to raise absolutely not i just want
to say like not helping is a nice way to
phrase it it's harming corrupting
corrupt let's go as far as it corrupts
okay for sure yeah i have no doubt about
that my my only concern is that
unaccountable people being able to do
something
completely without any type of
transparency
as a standard for it for the whole
country is to me
itself problematic in that
sense like i i do think that you know i
agree but at the same time i don't think
that i've seen
like a ton of egregious
well i think part of it is
part of it is that like you have to be a
giant i mean who's that guy what if the
person that ran youtube ended up being a
right-wing lunatic right this idea that
every that you know that the people that
agree with me are always going to be in
power or they're always going to do the
right things
one of the reasons that you try to
establish i think these standards that
remain
somewhat concrete not as vague is so
that no matter who's running an
organization you don't necessarily have
a problem i think this whole cons i
think
there is a victim complex on the right
they're all they think they're being
censored in truth i really don't think
they're being more censored than no i
think that when you look at it people
people look at the yes the leadership of
tech companies and they usually say
they're live well there's people on the
far left that have been censored too i
mean abby martin and chris hedges are
not right-wing so i don't think it is
only right-wing i mean dude like stephen
crowder for example he's out there like
re-enacting the george floyd uh
murder for chits and giggles and he's
fine he's still on youtube right so i
feel like they're pushing it and the
thing is there's communication yeah
these people have a vested interest in
playing up the victim and there may be
stuff with tate that i don't know things
i haven't heard i'm sure there is i'm
sure
i'm not saying that i'm fully aware of
it all right i'm just saying my my
initial reaction is always to question
i'm a teacher what's going on right and
i by the way my i'm not trying to like
my my intention is not to ambush you or
something like no no no no i i don't
feel like that i oh this is listen i'm
always i talk this is what i do okay
good yes so i think that's interesting
because i think the natural impulse for
a lot of people is to be like oh let's
not censor people but i wonder what's
the secret i'm thinking about delighting
in the censorship of your enemies and
going oh these people disagree with me
let's get rid of them because i think we
all know that if certain people had
their way it wouldn't only be hate
groups it would be anyone that disagreed
with them so there are people that hold
political positions that are different
and they could easily be described as
hateful right where this is the most
contentious or one of the most
contentious periods in our country's
history so if it was easy enough to just
say we could all identify what a hate
group was and exactly how they behaved
but there's people that would advocate
banning people that are
you know
congressmen and senators and whatever
and then the reality is it's like but
that's not happening right yeah of
course it is there are people that
advocate to getting all of these people
off right advocating or is it happening
what happened with trump
so that was right yeah i understand
let's be honest well for sure but there
isn't any [ __ ] that guy was running
he there is loose for a long time i do
not disagree
people on twitter were like you have to
stop you can't say this you can't say
this i know because i talk to people on
the back in the uk yeah for sure and
people people who get banned have a
vested interest in playing the victim
complex fundraising
and then they they don't [ __ ] mention
all the times yeah that they had like 20
sit-down conversations with youtube
where they're like listen you can't say
this right you can't do this
we're warning you yeah it happens don't
they say oh i've suddenly got banned
so right so it's just they're not
characterizing it
part of the issue is
when you
when you remove the president of the
united states yeah you have elevated
yourself you are now above
like you know some of the most powerful
people in the world as this company and
a lot of people are deeply uncomfortable
with that but now people might agree
with trump and saying i i think a
timeout would have been good you know
it's dope yeah
that
trump is not a [ __ ] king
no no and they can
silence him if they want for sure so
[ __ ] him he's just a guy yeah by the way
yeah let's not pretend like trump
is being uh you know hamstrung the man
is the [ __ ] president he's not half
strong everybody he's not hammered all
the time but i'm saying that's what
people
question they go this is an incredibly
powerful
group of people that can shut off the
president of the united states so
whether you agree with it or not the
idea that it can happen
is troubling to people worry about that
people just go you know i don't
necessarily know how comfortable i am
with people that have that level of
power um and that's something that it's
not an easy thing i don't think it's uh
i i don't think it's an easy
situation i think there's more
complexity than just saying
well there's people at youtube they've
had a bunch of meetings when they make a
decision it's something there's
literally nothing to do about it other
than nationalizing social media well i
think that's
certainly a debate i don't know that
that's going to necessarily fix
something but
well of course it will because if the
government owns it then the first
amendment applies
i think we all use social media for the
pros and the cons yeah i mean it comes
with benefits and it comes also with
this trump got elected probably because
of tweets because of social media so
yeah he said a lot of [ __ ] he got a lot
of um warnings a lot and that's what
happens yes
i i just am generally uncomfortable with
and that's fine total that's fine yeah
power but still there needs to be
times when people need to be [ __ ]
kicked off yeah i'm sure that they're
all for sure and absolutely who's gonna
make that decision that's the question i
don't know and that's the question but i
i agree that there's times where people
go way over the line yeah but it's just
about
who makes those decisions how they're
made
and i think it's a little more it's a
stickier situation especially in the
hate speech concept where it's like
there's a lot of things
that some would qualify as hate speech
to certain people and some wouldn't
there's a lot of like
easily defined hate speech bubbles that
i think apply which is like homophobia
transphobia
is not an easy bubble right that's not
easy at all so if somebody says a man
can't get pregnant and that's their
belief
somebody might go that's a hateful
statement somebody might go that's a
statement that's rooted in biology they
can have that debate you could hate it
or disagree with it but the some people
will consider certain things hate speech
yeah that are opinions true yeah but i
don't think people are getting banned
for saying that i do think there are
instances where people have been banned
for the trans or expressing positions
that were anti the mainstream i think
that when you look at each specific case
you'll find that this person
what went above and beyond
in in their quest too and that's very
possible i have not looked at each
specific case but i do yeah jk rowling
is like what people call her turf
whatever she says that [ __ ] all the time
right or she's nothing ever she never no
for sure
for absolutely i'm just saying that like
that's an example right there of like
that is a that is
harder i see to carve out what's what's
real hate and where people are having a
genuine and passionate disagreement sure
but i i don't think you should be able
to tweet
like crazy stuff at people
and you know at groups of people like i
do believe that there needs to be like a
line yes for sure yeah yeah yeah it's
just not
as easy always to establish what that
line is yeah that's all
right yeah obviously right there's
nuance to it right there's just nuances
i just see we have to deal with it on
the daily when ethan makes a bad joke
and yeah i don't think anyone would get
banned for a week right i mean it's just
part of our business again all the time
right like for example recently i said
and don't say it
oh you can you just i'll tell them what
i said
you can cut yeah yeah yeah yeah
did you see that whole follow-up i see
it but i can imagine a big story donald
trump jr was tweeting about me yes and i
got busted i got kicked off for a week
right yeah
yeah i mean sometimes timeouts you know
would that be such a bad thing by the
way no i i i don't know they didn't know
what i said they don't know what i said
it could be argued that they do know
what you said so don't no i didn't say
it right right i thought you meant the
time out as with that yeah that's what i
meant that's what he meant yeah
got my finger on the button ethan
where's my machete no
that was a joke by the way okay we're
not as far away as we think the way that
i see it andrew tate because i'm i'm
very aware of it you might know more
about me and yeah because i don't know
maybe right maybe possibly yeah i see
him as a hate group where you know like
jews yeah blacks
uh uh uh muslims yes uh trans gays
they're protected groups of people right
just
so to speak yeah yeah so so when it
comes to women you know it's like
you should never know
nobody nobody's speaking up like in the
same way sure and i think that as a
group of women this he's advocating for
violence against if he's advocating for
violence against women then that is
absolutely absolutely is yeah i i the
things that i'd heard were these trolly
kind of misogynistic things but none of
them were like let's hit women it's not
truly that's what you learn when you
watch enough of his stuff he is funny
and entertaining right yeah that's the
problem you know but a lot of a lot of
[ __ ] uh
a lot of the fascists and psychos and
[ __ ] they're very uh charismatic for
sure yeah you know for sure
also there's kind of a phenomenon i've
noticed amongst like white nationals and
nazis online they talk about everything
like it's a joke
but they're not joking you know what i
mean yeah there's an irony yeah it's all
about irony yes it's like
anyway watch this i i think this is
interesting okay yeah
and i teach sixth grade
um we've been in school for three days
now and within these three days the
amount of
young 11 year old boys that told me that
they love andrew tate is ridiculous
this man is
really affecting the minds of young men
i had a boy today 11
turned to a girl and tell her that she's
fat
women need to be thin
she sits at home and she eats all day
and that she's like every other girl in
the world
and that she uses men
to get money and at least he's a
hard-working man and he works for his
money
you know
they're 11. 11 year old did that yeah
but but yeah which is like that's not
great no exactly and there's actually a
lot of examples of this because school
just started yeah and there's kids that
[ __ ] look up to this guy and so i
don't i don't know why as a parent
you're letting your child 11 year old
watch andrew tate videos well it gets
more yeah it gets more complicated than
just letting your kid watch because like
some teachers said that some kids are
kids of immigrant parents and they don't
understand english they don't they see
the kids picturing like you know your
parents going like hey we got you a
birthday present 12 months at hustlers
university
no no it's not like that not to be great
parenting right and it seems to be
impossible it's not yeah there's not
some obligation uh for the parents but
ultimately
they can't control everything right yeah
so i don't know
we've seen conversations no it's it's
interesting and
you know i i didn't think his shelf life
was going to be long either way i didn't
either whether he was banned or not i'm
surprised it happened so fast though
well i think things usually do
i noticed you said one thing where
you're like well he was doing misogyny
before and he was yeah you can't poli
you're right you can't police like every
person well for sure but what i'm saying
loaded up yeah you floated up i also
think like there is there should be some
acknowledgement of what what he is
speaking to
which is perhaps there's a hole in the
market for sane rational
positive male you know like you know
what i mean we've done that for a long
time yeah like where they're not you
know we don't need we obviously are not
needing to say what he says but like
jordan peterson there might not be right
right that's it that's his whole thing
yeah but there should be maybe more
positive
male
uh speakers and role models that are not
right that don't have machetes
i totally agree man
and that's a problem i wish somebody
could break through to these guys who
wasn't like a psychopath well i think
some of it is that people do like humor
so people do like people to be funny um
i think what he says very
uh a lot of it is very shocking and it's
it's the opposite of everything they're
hearing so it makes it fascinating
immediately but it has
crazy negative
implications
hopefully that there could be somebody
that wouldn't be
i think we can do that together we need
to do the um i would hope so what would
be the name of our course from hustlers
university we could be the yeah
let me tell you right now it would not
be one of the bigger ones
uh it would be like a
it would be a
smaller course um yeah i'm trying to
think of what the name would be
um
hustler well not a hustler yeah
oh funny and unfit like fresh funny
effect or just we'll just call it like
hot dog drinker university hydro drinker
two fat idiots and then everyone will
click on it because you'll go oh it's a
hot [ __ ] and then it's just us
telling people that because here's the
thing a guy like me telling you to get
up and go to work doesn't do anything
right because by the way i mean it fits
your room yeah in your room you need
like a bold like boxing kickboxer to go
put your sock in the drawer but if i say
it it's just like shut up you fat you
[ __ ] yeah no one cares right but but by
the way it's guys like me that have been
seeing it forever right it's like people
that look like you're back in the room
part of it upsets me that people need
this right right yeah
do we really need to clean our rooms
well it depends how bad they are yeah it
depends how bad
they are i have i first of all i have
cleaner i've made some cleaners for
example yes yeah so i don't like i'm not
a guy who
even let's say yeah let's hypothetically
say i'm cl i'm neat yeah let's say
i don't like making my bed and i don't i
hate it exactly so so what is this like
let's just clean our room a little bit
that's what there's there should be a
space for people like us that have other
gifts
exactly we should have
like oh make your bed or stay at that
scene of the accident we should be able
to
do our own thing we have a different
thing
i loved seeing jake paul speak against
henry and rotate what a great moment in
masculinity and i think that's exactly
what you're describing though it's like
this guy that like all these kids do
look up to him
those same boys you know what i mean
yeah you don't you don't listen wait
what didn't jake paul also tweet that it
was like a travesty that he got censored
did he yeah i think he did yeah oh you
did yeah he was one of those just take
whatever half you agree with
that i miss the internet you know let's
not no i saw both both okay
he said before you compliment him i'll
just show you this in there okay yeah
i don't roll with andrew tate
his ass out in the ring one day but i
roll with freedom of speech baby
hate speaks on the gospel again freedom
of speech means the government doesn't
lock you up for saying something yes i
think that yeah that concept nobody's
getting locked up yes and let's be
honest social media is not essential
right you learn that when you take three
days off twitter it is not essential i
think he is at all hustlers university
will endure
it'll live forever that'll be it's an
institution it will be fine yeah it'll
be a brick and mortar yeah yeah
there'll be an endowment
but you know what i mean it's like
social media is just not it's not
essential it's really not i think
there certainly is aspects of your life
to get a lot better without it but then
there's also things that
you know a lot of times you needed to
just participate in like the
conversation well here let's go let's
move on to
even uh diceier one i know you're a fan
of dicey dicey here we go schwab
i thought you're gonna say alex jones i
was gonna say alex jones i was doing a
dicey dicey
yeah i don't know no i don't agree
without what alex did alex and i met
i've met alex three times i know your
producer's like he's him at alex jones
date but i've met
i've met alex
three times and i've listened to alex
for very long time but super
entertaining nobody
co-signs what he did right that is not
anything that anyone co-signs that i
have ever met
right unless they're really well some
people do but right but ultimately he
runs into the same problem that you do
with a guy like tate he's
yeah he's funny as hell he's smart he's
right about certain but entertaining
well he's right about certain things
about certain things that the media
doesn't report on so it's right here he
also makes a lot of money from a scam
product right he also
so actually have do you not like the
colloidal silver i was just gonna say um
i actually just bought a uh baby wipes
made out of
seaweed
but this is what happens when the media
is owned by five corporations they
choose what stories to run and what
stories not to run and guys like him are
able i mean listen this is the truth
right i mean the media supported the
iraq war the media covered for you know
people setting up you know
a labyrinth of secret torture prisons
the media has held water for a lot of
horrible stuff so when you have these
independent guys that are crazy and are
wrong a lot of the times
they are in their their entire turf is
created by the fact that the mainstream
media acts as stenographers for the
government and just writes down in a lot
of cases what the government information
they want to be public right but someone
like alex jones he gets you in with the
nibble of truth
and then he [ __ ] goes nut like he
goes off he talks about stuff that you
know you can find other places he's not
the only one saying it you yeah you know
but he's the most entertaining one yeah
that's right but then when he starts
talking about like you know standy hook
was engaged
that's bannable right defensible yes for
sure okay okay
that's yeah yeah if people are showing
up at the houses of dead
kids yeah yeah okay there you go they're
not 100 we agree on that we do it i
guess it wasn't that controversial
no i mean that particular thing when
he's going out and you know
saying that these kids are faking their
deaths or if if that is what i believe
yeah that's what yeah they've made a
case afterwards the parents are actors
yeah we need to get to the bottom of it
and we need to do this and then people
have been harassing the families yeah oh
yeah i mean of course yeah
but that's hate speech sure and that's
been but in the beginning it was very
like
what he actually said
there was some weird gray area but
listen a jury just delivered a huge
verdict for those families so there was
clearly they showed him probably
engaging in behavior that basically was
kind of like targeted yeah kind of
harassment yeah if they returned yeah
which is again i think targeted
harassment is 100
percent bannable and i don't think
there's any serious person kind of crazy
though would disagree with that it's
kind of crazy though when targeted
harassment can you targetedly harass a
whole group of people
i mean it depends what you're saying of
course you can right if i come out and
say i don't like acts and we should do
something about them and we should hurt
them or we should somehow then yes
they're a little they're they're smarter
than that they don't outright say [ __ ]
like you know but if you disagree with
people and you say i don't believe what
they believe i believe this to be true
of course they believe that to be true
of course but when you're saying stuff
like you know let's just take jews as a
guy because so i can talk about it
there's you know jews will not replace
us this is the kind of stuff you hear
george soros which is like a [ __ ]
jewish uh dog whistle well people could
disagree with soros okay but i'm just in
totality you say jews will not replace
us no jews around that
and you yeah
you build this like yes this vibe this
energy yes that these are a group
of nefarious evil doers yeah and and and
so they come to a solution that they
were guided very intentionally to
without saying oh we need to eliminate
jews they're they're pushing you there
right over and over and the message is
obvious to everybody who's participating
in that without them yeah so that's what
i say is obviously like targeted hate
right yes i i would agree that that 100
is sure but i also think that like
there are issues that are you know when
for example if people say i don't like
globalism and a lot of people say well
that's a jewish dog whistle well it
might be but it's also an economic
system that you can criticize you can go
free trade has shown you know its
benefits to only people that are
wealthier on the upper end and some
people disagree with that and they say
well no it actually goes but i agree
yeah you can say globalism and a
globalist or people that bull and then
there are people that go i'm more of a
nationalist i think we should do things
more uh and all of these things can kind
of be dog whistles because racists exist
and they will use anything more about
the totality right yeah for sure
i don't like globalism nobody's going to
come all out and say it's it's more
about the totality of yeah i think
listen
100
i think but
but
the the fact remains it's just a more
difficult issue than you know there are
egregious examples where it's like these
kids have faked their own death let's go
to their family's house that's that's
bad that's an egregious example yeah
yeah and then there are people that are
like okay is this a dog whistle or is
this not and that's where it gets a
little tougher
right right it is yeah you have to know
what's in someone's heart or head and
that's what's difficult i think to
really make and not always sometimes you
see it it's not though maybe that's what
i say maybe it's not maybe sometimes
it's then we're making ourselves into
gods right we're saying it's not god
it's twitter well i know but we're
saying like i know exactly what this
person means
this is fine room this is my this is our
future uh university
clean your room we're just sitting in it
lesson number one hot dog drinker
university we should run a hustlers
university community college oh okay for
people that can't afford it i get the
credit transition you transition from us
to hospitals
if you save enough money that's awesome
i think that makes sense yeah get some
college credits yes on misogyny
um
well i'm glad you agree on alex i didn't
expect that i hope i still get it does
teddy fresh make three x
i wear the dogs yeah do i still get a
hoodie yeah of course i worth 3x um no
that that example 100 you cannot
target i mean that was yeah it's crazy
yeah and i even think he might agree
he probably he might he might he might
agree with that i mean he didn't even
contest yeah i don't think he i think if
you got if he was on the show he might
go yeah yeah oh that was [ __ ] up yeah
that was that was [ __ ] up yeah no that
was you know that's i've not heard one
person defend that
right okay
there you have it yeah
tim dillon says
death to alex jones
[Laughter]
no we
you know one of the things that i think
really is a problem
is that a lot of people that are and
somebody said this once on my show
because it's not good for society when
you have people that are a mix of right
and horribly wrong
so this becomes a big problem when
someone can be correct about something
and then horribly wrong about something
else
that creates a very potent mix that is
not good yeah yeah yeah it's kind of
hard i think our country just
from its onset was kind of doomed from
the beginning i mean the civil war
really were just uh picking at the
wounds of of the divine division
back then we're gonna have a few more
years where it'll be nice and let's just
enjoy it yes
let's enjoy postmates while you can
soon the driver won't make it to your
home yeah that's what as long as those
sushi things get left on the on the
doorstep not pounding that you know
let's just let's count our blessings
yeah that's true right you know that's
the truth yeah
there it is there it is said it all
folks we did
yeah um
but you know it's like
i guess one thing i wanted to touch on
we were touching on is like
you know it's just [ __ ] social media
yeah are we playing gods by saying well
i've analyzed this guy and i've
determined
he's [ __ ]
you know causing uh violent
uh hate towards jews
so right
so
is that playing god well i think that
there it depends in because these are
all case specific yeah these are all
they're so case specific
that when you have
a public domain which social media is
it's where people get heard now right
um so it becomes a concern where if they
are unilaterally kind of removed their
ability to
uh participate in the conversation for
example if you are
uh if you have two people running for
congress and you ban one of them
the other one has a tremendous advantage
so now you're kind of indirectly
meddling in an election sure right yeah
so this because these are these are
difficult issues they're not easy issues
i don't have the answers either right i
don't have the i can't say like i'm 100
in the camp of 100 free speech because
then you're gonna have people like again
harat targeting people harassment
and i'm not fully in the camp of like
let's just let them figure it out in
silicon valley i mean it's a it's it's
it's not easy i mean one thing
you could do
is just play by the rules you know like
you you're given warnings it doesn't
just happen overnight like we deal with
it daily so that is the truth you get
rules yeah and you can either play by
the rules or take the risk sure and i i
think it's about a lot of people are
don't know what the rules are and the
rules no no change someone like trump is
very smart well he's i don't think i
think the rules kind of i mean they
changed with covid right he just thinks
that the rules don't apply to him
right
if trump was flagler freak
again it's like
there's
a space here
that
we we need more transparency it will
never happen though there's really no
way to do it is there
i i just worry about if we like people
what do we do about it do you have any
idea i do not have the answer or any
idea any some more public uh more of a
public
process regulations government
regulations perhaps perhaps more of a
public process maybe some type of
i don't even know like there were
certain parts of the internet that were
very decentralized before these big
companies where things are more crowd
but yeah i agree that has problems too
whenever you don't have that much
regulation it just ends up all being
about like
nazis and pedos and you know mass
shootings it's like no we don't yes i
don't even pedophiles i don't think
anybody wants it it's like completely
what i don't want to say the wrong
website but like a-chan right or
whatever the one is you don't want to be
completely unmoderated but i also think
within the world of what is what is
appropriate and not appropriate there
are people's thoughts on that evolve
over time and the issues social issues
political issues there's a very very
contentious period and people have very
very different views on what should and
shouldn't be allowed to be said yeah i
mean that is just an inescapable fact
yeah
that kind of is where you i think if
people are unable to communicate with
each other you will just see more
violence so i would want people to be
able to speak and
that i think
will like those those those websites i
don't want to mention their names but
like
there's probably a purpose they serve
just letting people say the most
horrible [ __ ] and then for whatever
reason they're kind of like hey
it is what it is and then yes some
people do really horrible things and
those things are are not obviously not
the desired outcome
but there's a place to say [ __ ] up
stuff right so i think there should be
there are places
for sure like 4chan 8chan yeah these
kinds of ways yeah i mean these are
places where you can pretty much say
[ __ ] yeah [ __ ] and they do yeah
but you know i get i totally understand
that you can't have a completely
unmoderated
space i don't think anybody it's part of
the price of us being able to enjoy
everything that we get from social media
yeah no i i i run our business yes for
sure because of social media i don't
think it can be completely unmoderated
i just think that there's there's a lot
of issues that are that can get great
there's great yeah absolutely and you
know
huge groups of people have different
opinions about it right you said for
sure are you into astrology
not
a ton because i could be persuaded
giving me classic aquarius vibes i am an
aquarius yeah yeah you're a quanturian
thinker
so aquarius i don't know
wait are you today is this the beginning
of a day i'm just loving that
this is a coffee day i'm a cancer yeah i
feel like this is the beginning of a
like a a west hollywood coffee date and
you know what it's actually going well
i want to say cancer and aquarius get
along i think they do
individually cancer and aquarius zodiac
signs are good at friendship
yeah good friend
how about that we're both loyal and
caring yes
cancer is the zodiac for nurture
interesting and we'll drop anything for
a friend in need while aquarius values
their friendships above everything else
even their romantic partners yes i kind
of agree with the friends for life
friends for life there we go
what's your sign
sagittarius you're such a sag
such a sagittarius energy that's so sad
not wanting to entertain to attack you
with a machete
very sad
beta sag
yeah i mean we've said it all you want
another hotel uh hot dog no i'm gonna
skip it i don't want to be greedy
thank you for having me we're gonna
we're gonna pass those around the skid
row after this thank you for the nice
things you said about this special love
this method i really appreciate it the
special is
uh a real heroin hero thank you and you
are a real hero well that's very sweet
as you explain is it's very
thank you thankful to you thank you
everybody thank you for coming on right
and are you touring you want to plug uh
not really right now okay just to tim
dillon
i'm pouring on the internet podcasting
yeah
thank you thanks so much thank you god
bless
hot dog cocktails for everybody
thank you
[Music]
so